that he was going to be here
good morning everybody it is now 10 so
we'd like to get going here we've got a
busy day excuse me a busy day ahead I'm
gonna have a busy term ahead I don't
know if you guys have
taken a look at all our bills that we
have coming down the pike but we're
going to be probably about the busiest
Committee in the state house before we
get going Let's uh I'll rise and uh I'll
Lead You In The Pledge of Allegiance
yeah
I congratulations to the flag of the
United States of America
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you I think the first thing we
shall do Mr clerk is take a roll call
uh I believe I have that all done okay
checked everyone off it's here it should
be all set okay
um could you just mention uh the ones
that are not here we have a couple
missing yes uh representative uh yokola
Tetro tree 11. and that's it
and brown okay okay thank you
all right so I've a lot allocated about
30 minutes for uh an orientation
um we sent out a pretty lengthy few
sheets of paper
um kind of giving the expectations of
the committee for this for this term
um and My Hope was that everybody's had
a chance to read
that understand that and then if we had
any excuse me any questions on that we
could go over that uh in this first 30
minutes
so first of all did everybody get a copy
of that
or did anybody not get a copy of that
okay that was sent via an email from
Heather if you didn't get it
um
make sure you do get it so you can go
over it so we we're all on the same page
going forward for the term
um
did anybody have any specific questions
regarding the what we sent out and then
I've got some additional notes after we
sent that out of course I thought of a
bunch of things we forgot and uh
Vice chair power has some comments also
so were there any comments or questions
on
what was sent out
yes thank you Mr chair I have a question
about
um scheduling executive sessions yes
it's my understanding that in this term
um it is your prerogative to schedule an
executive session but it has to be with
the concurrence of the ranking member
that's correct so if we could work at
some point work out a process that feels
comfortable to both of us for that that
might be productive that's fine
um as of right now just say I'm kind of
getting into a couple comments that I
we're going to make at the end of today
but
um as I mentioned in the opening we have
a very very busy schedule coming up this
term
we're already at I think 46 bills and
that's going to probably climb north of
80.
um so
in this packet I mentioned that there
might be a need for more than one day a
week and I can already tell you next
week we're going to be doing two days so
plan on next Wednesday uh similar to
today where we'll be going over a number
of bills that that will be posted today
and then on Thursday we will either do
an entire day of
exacting or
um
a half day of exec executive session and
a half day more bills so
um representative save us we will get
together with you and we'll we'll go
over that
were there any other questions on
what I sent out
okay I see no more there
um
all right I've talked about next week
yes
um representative uh Vice chair of
powers got a few comments
thank you Mr chairman so committee
members I just wanted to
um let you know with regards to
storing personal
items or papers for this committee that
we have individual file drawers they are
located here in the back of the room
they are no longer in the
secretary's office so feel free to
utilize those as you see fit
yeah
so additionally I'd like to go over the
procedure for those that are giving
testimony
um and especially for the lobbyists that
typically show up here in this committee
room so the procedure this term will be
that when you come into the room and you
would like to provide testimony you will
obtain one of these pink cards fill it
out
um build number obviously is at the top
then you will put the Ping card under
the metal part of the clipboard
on the blue sign-in sheet
please do not come to the front of the
table please do not pass the cards
via the end of the table they are to be
placed on the clipboard the for the blue
sign-in sheet and there will be a
designee that will obtain the pink cards
prior to the opening of the hearing and
then we will call the speakers thank you
okay thank you for that
um one of the other
issues I wanted to mention was
um
excuse me
representative Manchester
thank you Mr chair uh this is the device
chair
um to have the pink card sometimes a
colleague or somebody else is testifying
in another bill in another committee if
they come after the hearing has started
what would be the process to give a pink
card at that time
thank you representative thank you for
that important question so in that
instance
um what would occur is that we would go
through the pin cards and the chairman
at the end of testimony typically will
ask the people in the room is there
anybody else that would like to give
testimony and at that time we can sort
that out then
thank you
um the other point I wanted to make that
I hadn't really mentioned in the the
initial package was a lunch I'm gonna
try to hold at a minimum one hour lunch
or I yeah about a one hour lunch and
we're going to try to make that at 12
30. I'm going to be scheduling bills and
exec sessions to allow from 12 30 to 1
30 is uh for lunch time hopefully we can
we'll be able to do that and that's just
for your planning purposes
okay
um
there's no more questions on the
orientation
package I sent out what I like to do now
is at 10 15 we're going to have all our
individuals who help us with our
committee the service to Ann Fitzgerald
Heather goalie and Christy ospressor I
believe is how it's pronounced we'll be
introducing themselves and let letting
them know what they do for our committee
um prior to that I wanted to go around
the room as quickly as possible just a
minute or two introduce yourselves let
us know who you are where you represent
um
just so we and pronounce your name for
me please so I when I call on you I
pronounce it correctly so um why don't
we'll just start down at that end and
then we'll alternate uh representative
lasellis
yes my name is rich rich lasalles I
represent the town of Litchfield this is
my fourth term here uh in the house in
my second term here with this committee
and I'm also a selectman so uh I look
forward to uh the term should be very
interesting thank you
foreign
thank you representative priests
good morning
um everyone I'm David priests I
represent District 17 in Hillsborough
County that is uh Ward 2 in the city of
Manchester this is my first term and I'm
very excited to be on this committee
thank you
thank you representative representative
Kelly
hi I'm Diane Kelly this is my second
term I'm Hillsborough 32 which is Temple
Wilton and New Ipswich
and I was previously on Judiciary and
I'm happy to be here
thank you representative Kelly uh one
reminder you just made me think when you
speak make sure you speak close to the
mic for recording purposes and so
everybody can hear
uh we are over to
representative Holland
I'm Al Holland I represent Stratford
District 20 which is Durham Lee Madbury
and a sliver of Dover Ward 4 and I'm
looking forward to working here
thank you representative representative
Cahill
I'm Tim Cahill I represent the town of
Raymond and I'm also the vice chair of
our zoning board
thank you representative Cahill
representative Hicks
good morning my name is Matt Hicks I
represent Merrimack 24 which is
concord's Ward 10 and I'm involved with
local planning boards and planning
commissions first term thank you thank
you representative
representative Elwood
thank you Mr chairman my name is Deborah
Elwood I go by Deborah
um I'm serving my first term I represent
District 5 which is Andover Danbury
Hills Salisbury and Webster and this is
my first term I'm very excited to serve
on this committee thank you
thank you representative representative
Gallagher hi I'm Eric Gallagher I
represent Merrimack County District 20
which is Concord Ward 6 which is right
down the street that way if the window
were open I'd point out my apartment
building which you can see
um yeah
um so this is my second term and also
second term on this committee and yeah
I'm looking I'm glad that I'm returning
uh representative Guthrie
I'm Joe Guthrie um my uh a selectman in
Hampstead I represent the Hampstead and
I have the this is my sixth term
um I uh my second term uh on this
committee I'm glad to see a lot of new
faces welcome I know you enjoy the
committee uh just as an aside I want you
to know that uh I'm the oldest member of
the house I expect some respect as we go
forward
thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative Guthrie how old
is the oldest member of the House 93.
impressive uh representative menchputi
thank you Mr chair I am uh I represent
uh Hillsborough 11 Nashua award eight
this is my sixth term and my second term
on Municipal and County government and
I'm on several uh non-profit boards in
Nashua and also have a Consulting
business with the housing so
thank you thank you
it didn't meet you prior so I assume
you're a Tatro representative
well no you're the you're not the only
one that mispronounces my name
it actually is pronounced Tatro
long a
um
ever since I
came to the house I've been on this
committee I've enjoyed it very much uh
this will be my
want to say uh I
fifth term I took
a little Hiatus the last two years and
now I'm back and I represent
Chester County the towns of Richmond and
Swansea
thank you representative uh
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair I'm Julie Gilman I
represent the town of Exeter in
Rockingham District 11. I I'm currently
a select board member in Exeter I've
served on the historic district
commission Heritage commission energy
committee several other committees so I
covered a wide range of things we'll see
here
this is my fourth term and my fourth
term on this committee
very good thank you
representative thank you Mr chair uh my
name is Laurel stavis this is my third
term in the house and my third term on
Municipal and County government my
favorite Committee in the house
um I am the senior member of the
planning board in Lebanon New Hampshire
where which I represent
um
13 Grafton County 13 which is uh Ward
one West Lebanon and I was also chair of
the West Lebanon economic revitalization
advisory committee I'm very pleased to
be here thank you
thank you
representative magiori thank you chair
majority
thank you Mr chair my name is Jim majori
representing Rockingham 23 which is the
town of Northampton uh where I am a
member of the select board have been for
five terms representative to the
planning board for a long time I serve
at the pleasure of the executive
director of the New Hampshire Municipal
Association where I'm on the board of
directors there also and serving in my
third term here in the house and my
third term here on this amazing
committee and I look forward to all
presidential trivia from my friend from
Litchfield thank you Mr chair
thank you uh representative yukela we've
gone around the room introducing
ourselves Europe
uh good morning uh representative
yokella
um I'm in my third term and I have been
um on
the local uh zba and budget committees
um for
a number of years five maybe six years
and uh
yeah what else is that was that what it
yep sounds good looking forward to
working with you guys thank you
representative McDonald
uh good morning my name is John McDonald
I am the representative from the
communities of Wolfeboro in Tustin bro
this is my third term in the house and
I've been the clerk for the past this
term in the previous term and I want to
apologize to everyone when I
mispronounce your name because I'm sure
I'm going to do that several times thank
you
thank you representative McDonald
representative power
thank you Mr chairman I am
representative Diane power I am from
Hillsborough County District 36
representing the towns of Brookline
Mason and Greenville this is my second
term in the New Hampshire House of
Representatives the first term I served
on this committee Municipal and County
government it was my second choice and I
am very pleased that I was placed on
this committee last year and
um
it is my favorite committee my local
government experience includes being
elected to the Hollis Brookline
Cooperative School District budget
committee where I served as the chair
and a member we have a lot of work to do
this year and I'm looking forward to
working with each and every one of you
thank you
thank you representative power
I see representative treeleven has
joined us would you like to introduce
yourself
am I going here
um
first of all let me apologize for being
so late I had plenty of time to get here
but the person in front of me wasn't
going anywhere and I was on a two-lane
road
but here I am
um Susan true Levin
I represent district 21 which is five
Wards in the city of Dover
Ward 4 is represented by another
representative and um
I have three excuse me two other people
who represent the
district with me
this is my
I'm entering my fourth term as a
legislator which
continues to surprise and Delight me
this is my fourth time serving on this
committee and like representative power
I'm very happy to be here it's just an
excellent group of people to work with
and
the issues
that face us are vital to um our entire
State of New Hampshire thank you Mr
chair
thank you representative uh I think on
the last one so I'll go uh
representative Len turcott I re uh
represent the towns of Stratford and
Barrington which is a new District
Stratford District Four uh interesting I
learned after being a resident of
Barrington for over 30 years that
Barrington and Stratford at one time
were actually the same town and it was
divided so we're once again United in
that respect uh this is my fourth term I
have been on labor committee my previous
three terms
um last term I in addition to labor I
served on finance the redistricting
committee and I was a senior advisor in
the majority office this would be my
first term in this committee
um
I didn't raise my hand for it but when
they asked me to do it I said sure not
realizing that it was going to be
probably the most busy Committee in the
house this year as we've spoken already
we've got a lot of bills looking forward
to it I already looked through many of
the bills I think we're going to have a
good year
and that is me so now we are going to
move on to
Heather
who's hiding in her office I believe
there she is
why don't you come in um also Ann is
planning on coming down correct
after you're done we'll have Christy
speaking if you could just ring her
thank you
breakfast
labor legislative Administration and
resources
a lot of different things I do a lot of
the scheduling and I scheduled studies
and statutory as well as
domestic standing committee
the folders that you go find in front of
you you have your bills that we've
received so far in their late
um you're welcome to take the girls home
and the folder but you you need to make
sure to take them home that you bring
them back this is your only company
we'll find copies of the bills on the
table when you have hearings but those
are basically for the public
sessions
thank you heather you did well if you
think of anything else let us know
um oh is that a question uh we have a
question for you
thank you Mr chairman so with regards to
the to the bills that will come in
subsequently where can or should the
members look to find those bills well
they on on
Thursday okay thank you
thank you
thank you Heather and just for the
individuals that weren't here right at
the very beginning
um representative power described that
in the back of the room here there are
file cabinets that with your name on it
that you can keep uh you know your bills
your files whatever you need to
okay uh Christy
thank you very much
okay we'll wait to see if Ann uh
Fitzgerald is coming down
um any uh Josh uh what excuse me sorry
representative yukela representative
treeleven anybody who came in late
um we earliest talked about the package
we had sent out uh titled in orientation
do you have any questions on that I
didn't think representative trelevin
would
and representative
okay
all right well we'll wait a few minutes
for see if Anne comes down if she
doesn't we'll start in on our bills
uh one other administrative item that
represent uh by Sheriff power brought up
if uh those of you in the who are giving
testimony have written testimony please
hand it to representative Lisette
lasalles
and he will pass it around the table
don't uh walk around in front of the
tables thank you it appears Ann
Fitzgerald will not be able to yeah no
she won't be able to get here for right
now so in uh
40 50 seconds we will open up our first
hearing
okay I see the time says 10 30 so we're
going to open up the hearing on
hb70
relative to residency requirements for
Deputy Town Clerks
uh call the first individual the prime
sponsor of the bill representative
edutant
welcome representative you are the first
individual to give testimony with the
committee this year
hope it goes well then
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
municipal and County government
committee my name is rep Josh adgerton
from Enfield and I'm here to introduce
hb70 a bill that would expand the job
pool for Deputy Town clerks and clarify
a confusing statute this bill came to
fruition after a conversation I had with
enfield's Town manager Ed Morris who
joins us today in November
the town of Enfield sought legal advice
about whether a deputy town clerk had to
be a resident of the Town obtained
advice that they did not appointed a
non-resident and then learned from the
secretary of state that the secretary's
interpretation of the statutes was that
the deputy had to be a resident while
the town was provided a workaround it
would be good to prevent this in the
future and we can do that with this bill
I will first speak to the statutory
confusion I know that attorney Grace
from the municipal Association has a
letter outlining one of the major issues
at root here
RSA 41 colon 48 says quote a deputy town
clerk must be qualified in the same
manner as a town clerk meaning they must
be domiciled within the town however RSA
669 colon 65 says essentially should a
town clerk no longer be town clerk the
selectman will make an appointment
unless there is a deputy town clerk but
only if the deputy town clerk lives in
the town which begs the question how can
an out-of-town Deputy town clerk get to
be Deputy town clerk if they must be
similarly qualified initially as the
town clerk put simply 41 suggests the
deputy town clerk must be a resident
669-65 suggests they don't have to be
at a minimum it would save a lot of
headaches for the committee to use this
bill as a vehicle to clarify that
language so towns know what the rules
are and the nhma will speak to that
speaking now to the merits of the
language here I think this legislation
has several clear benefits
per the most recent census data the
number of New Hampshire municipalities
with populations under 500 is 17. if
residency is a requirement the odds of
finding a qualified person to serve as
Deputy town clerk in a community the
size of Easton or Benton versus Bedford
and Londonderry are vastly different
smaller communities could benefit from
this kind of flexibility
this is an important adjustment to make
due to the necessity of town clerks in
the state of New Hampshire should a town
clerk resign or pass away there must be
somebody available to assume the
responsibilities of the job until the
next town meeting and that should be the
deputy town clerk as they are the person
with the most familiarity of their
specific Municipal needs
I'm not recommending that we alter the
requirement of residency for Town clerks
nor is nhma or any other testifier that
I'm aware of
in order of preference I am asking that
the committee passed this bill that
would allow smaller communities the
opportunity to find Qualified and
capable Deputy Town clerks who may live
in adjacent communities or at the very
least clean up and reduce confusion
within the statutes and that's all I
have I can take any questions
thank you representative are there any
questions
representative treleman
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for testifying
option in my head so I'm going to ask it
as a question the Assumption I'm making
is that when the law was
put in place and or written uh the world
was very different and our communication
was very different and for somebody to
learn about a town and its residence you
had to be there
again my assumption is that these days
you don't necessarily have to be there
all the time to adequately serve a town
in elected in a appointed position and
understand how the community Works what
do you think about that
I would actually ask
um that
when nhma testifies that they answer
that because there was a revision to the
rsas in the early 2000s that created
this kind of
um confusion it seems as if one part of
the RSA was amended while the other part
wasn't
um I don't 100 percent
I can't speak with certain confidence as
to which way that went but I know in my
conversations with attorney Grace that
came up so I would ask that he answered
that when he comes up great thank you
representative thank you Mr chair
uh representative Powell thank you Mr
chairman so my question
um pertains to the notion that
um
you testified that the change to this
statute here would expand the job pool
in communities that that are smaller
um
my town that I reside in is Brookline it
is a Border Town
does this legislation or as the prime
sponsor have you considered
um
the possibility of
um a deputy Deputy town clerk coming
from out of state is that addressed in
this legislation and what are your
thoughts
it's not specifically said no to
um however if an amendment were to be
drafted that would clarify that it would
need to be a New Hampshire resident a
minimum that I would support that but
foreign
thank you Mr chair
um just in terms of part of the answer
part of the question was uh
representative Powers asked and would
this address the need for us to have the
workforce having such a acute shortage
in terms of being able to recruit people
to serve in these positions would this
address
that critical need I believe so yes
representative Davis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question can you speak a
little bit to um
lines 9 through 14 uh with respect to
the town clerk position
um I think I understand the changes that
you're seeking in the existing
legislation here
and they pertain to should this become
law a deputy town clerk who is not
domiciled in the town could in some
circumstances serve as town clerk
if that position became vacant is that
what you're trying to accomplish here or
is it something different no it would be
allowing the deputy town clerk to assume
the responsibilities of town clerk until
the next town meeting
um that would be the parameters there I
will say as a disclaimer that
Municipal and Deputy town clerk
residency laws are not my wheelhouse uh
so
um I will do the best I can to answer
some of the more Cosmic questions
surrounding the rsas
um but though that conflagration between
the two not necessarily saying the same
thing
um is where I'm the most familiar right
now
representative yukela thank you thank
you for taking the question
um since the change does not
um address the requirement that town
clerks be domicide domiciled in the town
how
could
um
the
the the Selectmen
um appoint someone who is not qualified
to that position
representative can you repeat the
question so since their qualifications
require domicile in the town if for
Deputy Town Clerk or no for the actual
town clerk if the town clerk
moves out of town is no longer qualified
and now the deputy needs to come in and
fill that role but they're also not
domiciled in that town
there's no one kind of like
for the Selectmen to that meet the
qualification of town clerk to be
um
to be appointed that that's what this
legislation seeks to clarify I'm trying
to make it so that in the instance first
of all that a deputy town clerk could be
from an adjacent community and then
following that in the absence of a
regular town clerk the deputy town clerk
could assume those responsibilities that
is what I'm hoping to enable with this
legislation
foreign
for taking yet another question
I'm thinking about the article that I
read yesterday in the Concord Monitor
about a school board member who became
houseless
and was ousted from her position on the
school board because she could no longer
find a place to stay
in the ward that she represented and I
wondered if you might be amenable or
others might think it not a bad idea to
change the word domicile
to something else
like reside in or something like that
because domicile
implies to me that someone has a home
in that town
and we are seeing more and more across
this state that people are being
having to leave their home through no
fault of their own
so just it's just a shading of the word
and I'm just you know throwing it out
there is a possibility
if the committee supported that then
um I would support that but I don't know
how that would conflict with other
definitions within RSA and I would want
to be cautious about
touching that
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
I think I'm following up on on what uh
representative yokello might have been
asking does this
I thought I understood it clearly does
does this bill then essentially Grant a
deputy town clerk who is not domiciled
in the town and and assuming that role
the kind of leniency or or or whatever
until someone else can be appointed so
that they don't have to fill that
capacity of living in the town I didn't
state that question accurately I'm sorry
I think they would just be serving as an
acting town clerk acting town clerk
that's I think where I'm trying to go
okay thank you
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative so
um when I read this bill
sectioned um you know 41 18 and 669
colon 65 in in concert
the language is very confusing and
um so my question is
Mike let's see my copy here
um it would be a line
I guess 10 through 11. so the question
pertaining to lines 10 through 11 it
states that
um pursuant to RSA 41 colon 18 the
Selectmen have previously appointed
could you explain to me
that's not clear to me the English
language and under what circumstances
underneath the section dealing with a
vacancy that the Selectmen had
previously appointed a deputy town clerk
I believe that would pertain to whether
the appointment was almost grandfathered
in
um I
I think that speaks to a lot of the root
of the confusion here like as I stated
in testimony
um
669.65
appears to say that uh or the conflict
between 669 65 and 41 colon 48 is that
the deputy town clerk would have to be
similarly qualified as the town clerk
however in some
magic bait and switch circumstance where
the deputy town clerk was appointed
without residency then they could be
appointed except for uh where it was
conflicted uh I think our mutual
confusion in that statute uh is a good
argument for uh cleaning that up because
I am similarly confused
um yes go ahead just follow up thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
follow-up question so I spent a
considerable amount of time analyzing
this language and I also made a flow
chart so I'm thinking that perhaps that
word appointed should in fact be
approved because the procedure is that a
deputy town clerk is appointed by the
select board I meant by by the town
clerk excuse me and then that selection
is approved by the selectment so
um what I would say is this bill still
needs some work if I can say that
um thank you
sure and just to answer that
um as I said I am happy to admit that I
am not an expert in Municipal law
um so I would absolutely yield to the
accumulative experience of the municipal
and County committee to clarify the
language in this bill however I will
also say that what nhma is going to
testify to shortly is that when they
communicated and asked Deputy Town
clerks and town clerks across the state
of New Hampshire what does this say
there was not concrete unanimity in what
folks thought it believed and the fact
that that confusion exists should in my
opinion necessitate a fix to the RSA
um
that so I I I I agree with that
thank you uh if
I could if I could make a suggestion and
I'll let everybody ask as many questions
as they are but uh I might suggest that
maybe we move on to some of the other
individuals who are going to testify
that might have a little bit more
background on the actual language again
I'm more than happy to take more
questions but I'd prefer to go on to the
next would you still like to ask them
okay thank you representative Edgerton
thank you
uh next like to call Deputy Sarah
secretary Aaron Hennessy
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is Aaron Hennessey
and I am the deputy secretary of state
and I am here to
um I am here to offer testimony in
opposition to this legislation I first
want to point out that I
um agree with the representative from
anfield that the language in the current
law is a bit confusing surrounding the
deputy clerks
um and does need a little bit of Cleanup
in my research on this it was what I
found out and I'm assuming that the
municipal Association can give more
information I haven't read their letter
yet but
um that when we when the state addressed
this previously
much before my time in the state house
was that there were some deputies that
were not Town residents and the language
was written to try and grandfather those
deputies in while preventing new deputy
appointments from being members of a
surrounding town or as the
representative power pointed out perhaps
from another state
but it's
um the Department of State feels that
it's very important for members of the
clerk's office that are appointed to be
so
um which would be the deputy
and would take over in the absence of
the clerk to be members of the town
the qualifications for officers of town
government
under 6696 is that unless otherwise
provided by law no person shall hold an
elective town office who does not have
his domicile within the town so it's
very clear that town officers especially
the clerk in our opinion should be from
that town they um
the town clerks handle a lot of personal
private information when it comes to DMV
records when it comes to election
information but it's also really
important for them since they help to
run our elections and help handle a lot
of our voter information that these
people are Town residents that are
elected by the town and and are not in
any way controlled by anyone else in the
town in the town offices such as a town
manager or another elected official and
if these persons were to be from a
different town or appointed by the
select board then perhaps they wouldn't
be serving their constituents they were
elected by I'm assuming that the clerks
here and
anyone who else testifying can give you
some more information about the
importance of that I'm happy to take
questions that you may have but I again
I do agree that the language as
currently written is confusing and I
believe it was because they were trying
to grandfather in some deputies back at
some point point in the past
thank you thank you any questions from
the committee uh representative Tatro
thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
um
it
to me it's a little confusing
that the
in paragraph one it states that the
the change is that the deputy town clerk
did not
have his or her domicile in town
but under the town clerk
they required the time clerk which is a
constitutional
elected position
um be from the town you know to be
elected so how do you put a non-resident
into fill the town clerk's position when
they're not their resident
I agree thank you for the question
and and to your point the clerks are
mentioned in the New Hampshire
constitution in part second article 32.
thank you uh
let's make a quick reminder uh in the
packages that we sent out uh talking
about uh how we operate we have a lot a
lot of bills so we need to go through
this term if we can keep our questions
to the presenters actual questions for
furthering information
our points of view and our statements
I'm not picking on you representative
Tatro
um keep them to questions for
clarification that will move things
along much much quicker any other
questions representative Guthrie thank
you Mr Chan thank you for taking my
question would you agree with me that
the uh Deputy town clerk is a very very
important position and it's appointed
and that uh that
uh if there is nobody qualified in the
community particularly in the small
communities aren't we better to be able
to go out outside of the community and
get somebody qualified to serve in that
position of Deputy Clerk then uh become
committed to only people in the
community what do you do if you have
nobody I see this as as a plus
uh in the real world the deputy clerk is
a very important physician and that
person whether they come from the
community or not
the more important is that they're
qualified in and that it's not just
somebody in some of the small
communities I happen to have had a
situation where we lost our town clerk
and we had a deputy and a deputy served
for an a very short period of time
because the selectment in the real world
make that appointment as fast as they
can
so my question is don't you agree with
me that it's more important to get to
have a deputy clerk from
uh that's qualified whether they live in
the community or not
before you answer that
um
also in the packet representative
Guthrie that we we handed out one of the
items that I specifically mentioned was
that we again we need to ask questions
rather than uh
preceding our statement with a would you
believe again we're looking for
clarifications on testimony
unless I'm misunderstanding uh
Ms Hennessey has stated that she
believes that we should probably go back
to
um
the individuals actually residing
everybody residing in the towns and that
this this was created as a kind of an
exception to existing conditions if I
have that wrong Miss Hennessy you can
correct me uh you're corrected Mr
chairman um to represent Guthrie's Point
nothing in the current legislation
prevents a town from hiring assistant
clerks that do not reside in the town to
help with the operations of the office
foreign
thank you very much thank you very much
Mr chair I I'm
in my town Northampton we have town
clerk Tax Collectors same person elected
is that the way it is in every single
Town foolish should be not to know that
question I'm sorry and maybe you don't
know that either because I'm
I
I'm that that's my question okay thank
you representative
you can have the combined position there
is certain legislation that covers that
I mean in the rsas that covers that
however it is not how it is in in every
town
thank you
representative yakella thank you and uh
thank you for taking the question this
is kind of following up with my previous
question
um since this does not change
669.6 which you previously stated as the
requirements for residency for all
elected officials and we're not changing
the town clerk to not be an elected
official
um does this change actually do what
um the stated purpose of the bill is
which is to allow the Selectmen to
appoint someone to the town clerk that
is not
a resident of the town or domiciled in
the town since they would not meet the
qualifications under 669 6.
thank you representative yesterday
um an appointed non-resident Deputy
clerk that assumes the clerk role would
not meet the qualifications of the
position thank you
rep representative cholevin
thank you Mr chair and thanks so much um
Madame deputy secretary for coming to
testify my question is in your mind is
there a difference between
an acting Deputy Clerk
who might fill in while a clerk was I
think you've just answered it though
while a clerk was not available or moved
away or gone
I I don't believe so but I would have to
um I would have to get back to you on
that I I I'm assuming based on the
language that once they assume that role
that they have assumed that position I
hear you thank you
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um under the current uh 4118 it says
that each Town may have a deputy clerk
if a town that does have a deputy Clerk
and the town clerk leaves
let's see how what was my question if
the position of the Deputy town clerk
can't be filled by someone within the
municipality
does the position
is the position vacated
um thank you for the question so the
because it
um the law stipulates that they may have
a deputy town clerk that does not
require them to have a town a deputy
town clerk so I said as I said
previously towns are able to hire
assistance as needed to assist the town
clerk that are non-residents
thank you
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
deputy secretary Hennessey for taking my
question my question is are you aware of
any elected or appointed Municipal
positions in which there is not a
domicile requirement
I thank you representative I would have
to get back to you on the appointed
piece of of something but under the
rsa's anyone elected has to fulfill the
domicile requirement
thank you thank you Mr chairman
uh next we'd like to call Ed Morris I
believe
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
municipal and County government
committee my name is Ed Morris I'm the
town manager in the town of Enfield I'm
the one that called representative added
about this about this bill just wanted
to tell you a little bit about what
happened in the town of Enfield so we
had a retirement last year our town
clerk was retiring in December and we
had a deputy town clerk that did live in
the town that was going to move up into
that town clerk position so we we
started in September looking for a
part-time Deputy town clerk to fill that
position they looked hard they
advertised and and looked and couldn't
find anybody prior to advertising we did
work with nhma and they'll talk a little
bit and I think it's already been talked
about the confusion in the language
and um
we were advised that we could hire
someone from outside so when they were
looking for a part-time Clerk
they advertised like we would any other
position and looked for three months and
was not able to find a part-time Deputy
town clerk so the the town did what it
could and we actually moved the deputy
town clerk position to a full-time
position with benefits and knowing that
this was an important position it still
took until close to march to find
somebody that would fill this position
and we ended up finding a resident of
rumney New Hampshire that was willing to
make the drive about a 40-45 minute
drive from her house to Enfield to fill
this position
she's doing a great job
learn the skills of the position and
worked very hard for the town of Enfield
in August coming into the September
elections we were notified by the
Secretary of State's office that she
could not be a deputy town clerk and a
lot of the vital records and things that
she had had filled out and helped people
marriage licenses those types of things
needed to be redone and signed by the
Town Clerk and sent back so that was
great and then the Secretary of State's
office was really helpful they called
back a day or so later talked to Our
Town Clerk and said you know there are
towns around the state where this is
happening kind of here's the work around
and they said you know you can get a
stamp with the town clerk's name on it
for the signature and when the town
clerk's out of town the assistant town
clerk can do the paperwork and stamp the
signature and send it in or we could
deputize a select board member or
another member of the staff that was
domiciled in town to sign the paperwork
in my mind even though they don't really
know what they're signing and
um
to me what I teach my staff is if
there's a a rule that we're having to
figure out a workaround or something to
do then we need to go through the proper
steps to change that rule and so that's
why I'm here that's why I called
representative adjutant and asked him if
he would bring this legislation forward
so we can start getting some
clarification either clarification on
the language
the process or how we should do things
in the real world as he said this would
expand the pool and Fields a town of 4
600 people and we had trouble finding a
deputy town clerk for almost six months
I do think this will affect other towns
to work around with the assistant town
clerk works but I don't think we should
be creating laws to create workarounds
and so I would I would hope you guys
would support this or at least give it
good attention moving forward to
to present a law that that works for all
the towns
thank you questions uh representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so you had a lived
experience in terms of this whole
process uh as a town
manager was it conflicting to have a
task that would be normally done by a
city clerk but have the seal but
somebody else
as a
filling in could do it without
understanding what they're signing for
I don't know that it's
I don't know it's a huge problem but
it's a workaround I mean if the if the
lady's competent to sit in and do all of
the clerk's work
I don't know I don't understand why she
can't sign the document I do get some of
the concern if she's trying if the
emergency comes up where they need to
fill in for the town clerk for a couple
months until the town could find
somebody to do that job but
that's something that you guys need to
talk through and figure out but I know
the day-to-day work that the clerks do
every day
um we need someone in that seat and it
would make a lot more sense if the
person that took the training and
understand how to fill the paper work
out could sign the paperwork at the end
of the day
are there any other questions
seeing none I have a couple questions
for you uh kind of related
um being the town manager have you ever
had previous to the last couple years
have you ever had
issues in filling uh Town Clerk or and
Deputy town clerk positions
uh
I'm not sure about filling them I mean
we've had a little bit of trouble I was
the city manager in Claremont too much
bigger city
um we did have people there but we kind
of did the same work around there in a
big city there were times that we
deputized my assistant that's on the
other side of the building from the
clerks and the assistant clerks there
that lived outside of town would run
across the building over to her office
to have her sign a piece of paper so
they could send it in to the State House
kind of what I was getting at is I know
over the last couple years there's been
a
I hate
businesses government offices everybody
has been having trouble filling
positions and my concern a question is
do you think that that plays a part in
not being able to find yeah that that
absolutely plays a part I mean it's not
just the clerk or Deputy Clerk's role we
have a a lot of trouble finding
government employees
anywhere just like any other business
and then the requirements and the
training needs for all of these
positions are are getting
more and more so it's you know there's a
lot of training that needs to go into
these positions before people are
allowed to to do the work and
okay thank you seeing no other questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
uh next we'll call nature Grace
thank you Mr chair nature Grace for the
municipal Association I just want to
briefly introduce the municipal
Association since I know we have a new
committee
um so we do three primary things we
provide legal advice to cities and towns
we're a voluntary membership
organization we currently represent all
234 cities and towns so we provide legal
advice to them as they call us we
provide training which is probably our
biggest component of what we do last
year we had 86 different Education and
Training sessions that staff our staff
of of nine of which uh five of us
typically do trainings
um performed
and those ranged from working with State
agencies we took over some training that
state agencies had previously done as
well as independent trainings and
training suggested by legislators so
certainly if there's anything that's uh
that you see as a problem either
generally or in your municipality please
let me know we're happy to try to work
with you to address those issues and
lastly I come here and uh and I talk
with all of you about the positions that
our members adopt and ask us to advocate
for at the legislature and today I get
to begin with probably the strangest
testimony that you will hear from me all
year because we do have a policy
position of course to support our
members but we also have a policy
position to clarify the law
I have handed out a letter to all of you
in the first section there I have
um copied down the existing law
underlining what I believe are the the
relevant Provisions that are causing
some confusion here
um and then in the second section uh I
have a couple of statutory
interpretation rules which are very
important
and knowing that your chair has written
more contractual language in his career
than I have probably read
um I know he knows how important it is
to get things right and be clear
um so I'm sure he could talk to that in
executive session much more thoroughly
than I could hear but the courts
generally have two rules that are very
important for you to know as legislators
the first is that they don't look beyond
the language of the statute to figure
out what the intent is if they think
they understand what the statute says
and the second is that whenever possible
they give all words in the statute some
meaning
um and so in response to the town of
Enfield contacting representative
adjutant and us and letting us know
about this problem with the deputy town
clerk situation I went out I talked with
Municipal attorneys and as it turns out
there's some disagreement about what the
words in the existing statute mean
and the problem really comes in with RSA
669.65
which has a provision that says unless
the deputy does not have his or her
domicile in town so presumably there
must be some situation where a deputy
could not be a resident of a town under
existing law
um and this was actually a problem
created by the legislature back in the
early 2000s so at that point in time
they made a determination that it would
be inappropriate for deputies to be res
not be residents of the town so deputies
should be residents so they modified the
first two staff or the first statute
related to Deputy Town clerks which used
to say
um what this bill proposes in its first
section and it says they have to be
qualified in the same manner except they
need not have their domicile in town
um but at the same time the legislature
recognized that there are there were at
that time
um Deputy Town clerks who were in fact
not residents of the town and they
wanted to protect them in their
positions so they modified the vacancy
statute to include the language that I
cited earlier
um that has created some confusion
because if you were like the Secretary
of State you know what the legislative
history is you have that institutional
knowledge it obviously makes sense that
you would want to do uh what the policy
of the legislature was
um 20 years ago if you're uh 20 years
ago you were Middle School like me and
you became an attorney afterwards and
you read the statute and you said well I
think this is clear there must be some
circumstance your advice is going to be
well
obviously deputies don't have to be
residents of the town
so my testimony is strange today because
well we support uh the changes that
would allow deputies not to be residents
to the town for all the reasons you've
already heard today
um we
would support a a committee amendment
that modified the existing statute to
clarify that they must be residents
because as it is right now the statutory
scheme is confusing and we need some
clarity
um this comes into play a number of you
have asked questions today
um I think everyone in this room would
agree uh that town clerks and the
functions they perform are essential
realistically you can't have a town
running without someone performing those
functions whether or not they're a
resident so we really need to resolve
this issue in order to make towns
function well I know you wanted me to
keep my testimony short so I'll happily
answer any questions anyone has
thank you for your testimony questions
thank you Mr chair so it's the strangest
uh testimony yes
but uh my question to you is as you see
it
in having the history
of the municipalities
by clarifying that the deputy clerk can
only be an acting
in in case when the clerk is has to
leave or has left or
vacated the position
would that help because it's only an
acting
or
would it can create more confusion thank
you for the question
um just let me um Talk briefly about how
the current Deputy process works so
what happens is the town clerk
basically nominates someone to be the
deputy and that person is appointed by
the select board
that doesn't relate to whether they're
employed in the town clerk's office or
employed with the town that only relates
to what their statutory role is and
there are a number of things that the
town clerk can do the deputy stands in
the place of the town clerk when the
town clerk goes to Disney World for two
weeks
and that's really what we're trying to
um balance the policy on is well what if
the town clerk leaves
um you know before town meeting happens
um
you know how do we fill that position
until you know someone in town steps up
um and runs for that position obviously
it has to be a resident of the town that
becomes the town clerk
um and the second part of the bill
changes a show to a May
um and part of the reason behind that is
as I recall from my discussions with
representative adjective was you may be
in a situation where you have a town
where a couple people step up and they
say I'd like to become Town Clerk and
the select board obviously if the select
board appoints one of them that's
basically saying this person we think is
best qualified voters you should vote
from it's it's basically an endorsement
the select board may not feel that's
appropriate but we still need someone to
do the town clerk function so it would
be
um the I guess sort of the preference
there would be you know we'd certainly
like someone to be appointed if there's
only one person definitely do that
but if two people stand up they're
equally qualified they're both residents
obviously
um but we can you know start the
training process get them familiar with
everything they would need to do as town
clerk but we don't want the select board
to interfere with that election by doing
basically an endorsement
representative uh yokelum thank you
thank you for taking my question
um same question I had before do you
believe that this as as stated this
current language of the law would allow
the Selectmen to appoint
a a town clerk that is not a resident of
the state
like knowing what I know now I will tell
you it's confusing when I read it the
first time I thought there must be a
circumstance where a deputy cannot be a
resident and therefore I mean otherwise
why would it say that in uh 669-65 in
which case
why would it need to be repeated
um above in um
4118.
so I now know the legislative history so
I'm I now know how it would be
interpreted by the Secretary of State I
know that background so my
interpretation would be different than
having read it the first time where I
thought the legislature was clear in its
intent
I can I follow up
a follow-up quickly yes thank you I
don't think that
um I must have stated the question
incorrectly if this law was to pass as
it was presented to us do you believe
that the selectman could then appoint a
deputy
um clerk to fill the role of town clerk
given that there's a qualification in a
different section of law that requires
them to be domiciled yes because the
modification would mirror what the
statute said prior to 2002 or three and
it says they're qualified in the same
manner except they don't have to be
dominance okay thank you
are there any other questions seeing
none oh uh representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair I was wondering if I
could recall uh this deputy secretary of
state because I thought of another
question that um I did not think of the
at the time if she's willing to do that
we'll do that after uh our next speaker
sure
thank you thank you
Mr Grace
oh okay
all right
um we next we have I believe it's Josie
Ewing
welcome
and
and even though on the pink card we do
have your position on the board we'll
remind those testifying whether you are
for or against the Bill thank you and
may I ask if it's okay that Dan Healey
my colleague joined me sure thank you
mm-hmm
thank you so much for having us my name
is Josie Ewing I'm the Plymouth Town
Clerk and I also serve on the New
Hampshire and City Town clerks
Association representing clerks in The
Lakes Region
I'm here today in opposition of this
house bill 70.
but what I would like to do because my
colleague here is going to give you a
more official stance from the New
Hampshire and City Town clerks
Association is wrap some of my
viewpoints from my role on the
association in a conversation that I had
with my deputy
when I had learned of this change
potential change to the role of Deputy
town clerk the first input input I
sought to seek from was my Deputy Clerk
I value her input and her perspective on
this I also come from a position where I
started as deputy and was elected to the
position of town clerk years later
reading the bill
through our discussion we came up with
intent and impact
but I want to start with impact
this bill would have negative
consequences to the office of the Town
Clerk and the constituents we represent
how you may be wondering
this bill does not in fact make an
appointed Deputy town clerk who's
residing out of town does not give them
the ability to complete or fulfill the
responsibilities of the town clerk's
position
that is a stance that we believe we are
in agreement with the Secretary of
State's office on
and that is because the town clerk is a
resident of the community she or he
serves in
I want to provide some education on what
the clerk does in her office
some of the responsibilities Town clerks
have
are
administer administering vital records
in their community
what does that mean well we complete
marriage licenses
we also complete paternities of
affidavits
we do amendments on Vital Records
that includes adoptions court ordered
court orders
and even clerical mistakes that were
made Down the Line This is confidential
information we would want the person
we've invested in our Deputy town clerk
who is a resident of the community to be
the individual who if they see this
information they have that long-term
role within the community whereas an
appointed official who's not serving in
the community they may see this
information but they would not
ultimately be able to fill fulfill the
position of town clerk and would soon
leave
one selection came comes
we also do Motor Vehicle registrations
now in communities uh towns already have
the option if they so choose to vote
they can separate motor vehicle
operations from the role of town clerk
and designate an appointed Municipal
agent to work on behalf of the state of
Department of Safety
but we also do run elections with our
fellow election officials the moderator
the Selectmen and the supervisors of the
checklist this is an area that is
concerning that my deputy and I talked
about is that we firmly believe that the
deputy clerk should be a resident of the
community because that Deputy is
essential in fulfilling many of the
responsibilities we do on Election Day
I can give you some examples in the
office we work on we accept absentee
ballots and applications
we do voter registration
among other responsibilities we also
know our community members and do
recruitment for operations and on
Election Day
many towns have had it excuse me issues
filling the positions of ballot clerks
and so in Plymouth for example we have
two three stations for official check-in
if someone uses the restroom for example
I might ask my Deputy town clerk to sit
and assume their responsibilities until
that individual returns
this bill would essentially make it so
if an appointed Deputy town clerk is
residing out of town
were in this position they would not be
able to assist in that capacity
and that's just one of the examples I
can provide
now I want to talk about intent I don't
believe the intent of this bill was
malicious at all
but it wasn't informed the New Hampshire
City and town clerk's Association was
never reached out
um from the New Hampshire Municipal
Association or representative Josh
adgerton what I would encourage is that
these individuals do work hand in hand
with the association
because there are some issues it is very
hard to fill a lot of elected capacities
even appointed
but this bill isn't solving the root
problem here
there's two issues one is education and
that is something that the New Hampshire
and City Town clerks Association is
really going to be focusing on moving
forward
is making it our mission to make sure
that people know what town clerks do in
their offices and we need to work hand
in hand with our other officials in
towns to ensure that our communities
really know the responsibilities of the
Town Clerk and their deputy
and then additionally is some of these
positions in towns they're not offering
they're not competitive
unlike other positions like fire chief
police chief a lot of those positions
have changing have changing actors
people who go in stay for five seven
years you'll notice that a lot of town
clerks even their deputies are in those
positions for 10 20 30 years or more
they've been left behind while the rest
of the communities have progressed and
modernized in their Styles and
competitiveness
many of these positions deputies may be
getting paid 13 14 an hour 15 might be
part-time no benefits
and then they're being asked to assume
that position to take on the role of
town clerk and many towns Town clerks
are not compensated well as what either
so there's a few root causes to this
issue I don't think it's an issue that's
affecting just Town clerks and their
deputies I think it extends and it's
broader than that
um
and there's ways that towns can manage
that moving forward I also just want to
Echo what deputy secretary of state
Aaron Hennessey had said is that
when it comes to certain or particular
responsibilities such as elections and
Vital Records Town Clerk or their deputy
should not be appointed uh
in the sense that
we do not want an undue influence over
the office
the relationship between the Town Clerk
and the state is vital
we are State agents just as much as we
are local agents
and we need to ensure that our practices
are supported by state laws rather than
potentially being threatened that if an
appointed Deputy town clerk appointed by
the board of Selectmen were not to
follow their wishes that the concern is
that they may be removed from office
potentially and we don't want that we
want we want our deputies and we want
Town clerks to feel secure in the roles
that they can practice current state
laws
okay thank you
um
uh Dan Healy okay uh first of all we
don't have a pink card on you you've got
it
um is the testimony gonna be markedly
different
um similar but short um if we yeah if we
could where the chairman has failed
miserably in his uh
timing of this first uh first bill so
I'd like to move it along so if there's
anything repetitious kind of leave that
by the side if you have something that's
new uh we'll hear it so Dan hilley now
Short city clerk uh vice president of
the New Hampshire City and town clerks
Association
and our association is against this bill
um the main reason that we are against
this bill is a deputy town clerk cannot
work elections that's one of the main
functions of the town clerk's job so if
you're a town clerk is ill or you know
not available for whatever reason on the
day of the election the deputy clerk
cannot fill in if they do not reside in
that community so that that's a major
concern uh for us
and I also don't believe that changing
the statue on the deputy clerk would
then allow them to ignore the
requirements for Town Clerk and step
into that position I think you'd still
need to meet the requirements of town
clerk
even as acting town clerk you would need
to fulfill the requirements of of a town
clerk I don't think that this bill
addresses that that part it only changes
the deputy town clerk
um so if a town doesn't have a town
clerk if the town clerk retires the town
clerk leaves they need a town clerk or
an acting town clerk so a deputy uh
would not be able to access vital
records and they would not be able to
access the election system unless there
is a town clerk in the town and that
situation happened to me when I left
Derry the state would not leave on vital
records in the election system without
an acting town clerk in place so I don't
think that a deputy that doesn't live in
town would meet the requirements to be a
town clerk and you would have no access
to vital records and you wouldn't be
able to
um
assist during elections and it's also
only a temporary fix so if you're saying
at the next town meeting then the A-Town
clerk would need to be elected that
lives in that town you could only be
talking a few months so the town's going
to be in the situation where they need
to fill that that role
either at that point or maybe just a few
months down the line
thank you okay thank you for your
testimony uh representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I think it's directed at both of you
and also at the deputy secretary of
state so the assistant clerk workaround
would not be usable if the clerk were
absent during an election
it would it would not be I I don't
believe unless all the assistants lived
in town I mean if anyone that lives in
town can work at the election
follow a coach and go ahead thank you
um and and so it's not really a
workaround is it it's it's not really a
workaround if you have the deputy
residing out of town you would still
need some someone who needs to be
appointed to
um to to carry out an election thank you
representative Guthrie thank you Mr
chairman uh and thank you for your
testimony particularly uh indicating how
important this Deputy is uh to the town
uh do you see this bill requiring any
Community to appoint a deputy that is
out of town
isn't it isn't it more of an option
so I believe the way the law is right
now is that towns don't need to have a
deputy so they wouldn't I don't see this
as uh them needing to appoint a deputy
right
a majority of responsible Town clerks do
have deputies they've appointed to
assume responsibility as if they are
unable to what this may do is further
confusion actually because
towns may think that by appointing a
deputy from out of town they may be
setting up that person for failure down
the line I think it we can all relate to
starting a position wanting to move up
and be able to grow
in that capacity really it's setting
that individual up for failure or
stagnancy where they wouldn't be able to
move up at all because of the election
the elected piece so towns May appoint
someone from out of town but the
emptiness of this bill is that that
individual can't fulfill the clerk's
responsibilities and neither can they
become elected if that position becomes
vacant and there's other things to
consider in this but it you know to in
respect to your question I won't go into
those but I hope that is a further
explanation thank you for your testimony
thank you
uh representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair this mate excuse me
this may be able to answer the question
that I was going to ask the deputy
secretary of state
um
can you tell me the definition of
certified documents uh Throughout the
chapter on Town Clerks
documents that need to be certified by
the town clerk so certified documents
would probably relate to the vital
records that we issue so as Town Clerk
or or Deputy town clerk were able to
sign at the bottom of the vital record
and then we put the town or city seal
over our signature and then it's a it's
a certified vital record
follow up Mr chair follow up
um I've as sitting on the select board
I've had documents that uh pertain to
federal grants that need to be certified
when we either accept the funds or make
the application and the line is here
appeared before me
so
how does this work around stamping
something and then having the person the
town clerk sign it later fulfill that
Federal requirement
so I believe the reference earlier was
on the vital records so any documents uh
like that grants and things as city
clerk town clerk we sign those directly
on the vital records it's an ink
signature
um because we larger communities we do
probably 50 to 100 certificates a day so
if the clerk's not there this gives
customers the opportunity to still
retrieve their records it still is an
ink stamp and it still is certified but
different depending on the documents
um like grants and things I would sign
directly but the stamp signature is a
valid signature that can be used for
those other documents on the the
day-to-day functions where the clerk
might be gone for a few hours or you
know on lunch it's not holding up
residents from retrieving records thank
you
okay thank you for your testimony uh we
do not have any more pink cards
I don't see anybody waving in the
audience
so
yes representative
thank you Mr chairman would you allow
the deputy secretary Hennessey to be
recalled I have a quick question
sure
um thank you
as long as it's a nice quick question
because we are way behind
foreign welcome back thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so
um very briefly during this hearing I've
heard testimony referring to the deputy
clerk acting as the town clerk
could you please
um clarify that because according to
statutory language under 669 colon 65
pertaining to vacancies of the town
clerk is my understanding that the
vacancy
would be filled by appointment and
therefore
the deputy town clerk would in fact not
be acting
as the town clerk that Deputy Town town
clerk would then become the town clerk
could you clarify that
um thank you for the question
representative uh my reading of um
669.65 is the same as yours in that uh
the deputy
would assume the responsibilities of the
clerk and my apologies
um the word workaround was referenced
before associated with the Secretary of
State's office
um I I didn't mean to infer that an
assistant in the town clerk's office is
a workaround to be in a town clerk
that that's not what um I had testified
to
thank you very much
see no more pink cards I'm going to
close the hearing on House Bill 70.
and
we will open the I want to apologize to
the uh those of you in the back who are
getting ready to introduce you bills um
I as I said before I have failed
miserably in my very first act as
chairman to properly time that first
bill so I apologize for that but we will
open the hearing now on House Bill 72.
and
representative Harvey have you uh filled
out a pink card representative
you you do yep okay just make sure we
get it afterwards
thank you
am I on yes my name is uh representative
Catherine Harvey I represent Cheshire
District Six which is Chesterfield
Walpole
um I'm sorry Chesterfield Hinsdale and
Westmoreland
um I am also the chair of the
Chesterfield Public Library Board of
Trustees I have submitted this bill it's
very simple it just changes the word and
to the word or
um so that
um RSA 202a15 would read The Librarians
shall have education of sufficient
breadth and depth to give leadership to
the use of books and related materials
the librarian shall be appointed by the
board of Library Trustees for a term of
office agreed to at the time of
employment and until a successor is
appointed and qualified I am asking to
change that to or until a successor is
qualified is appointed and qualified
I'm doing that on behalf of my library
Board of Trustees
because I live in a very very small
community Spofford is Tiny and it is
virtually impossible for us to comply
with the present RSA
if we lose a director for any reason
whatsoever it's hard to find a director
to take over and virtually impossible to
find an interim
we've lost in the past five years we've
lost directors because of a severe
Health Emergency we lost one after covid
who decided she really did prefer to be
a stay-at-home mom and we lost one
because the trustees decided not to
renew a contract
in none of these instances would it have
been feasible for the director to remain
in the position
until a new director was found as a
replacement as it says in the current
law and until a replacement is can be
found
there's no possible way I can say to a
director who wants to be a stay-at-home
mom no you can't do that you have to
stay here until we find a replacement
she's not an indentured servant
nor in our small community could we
always find an interim in in one
instance we were able to do so in a
second instance we offered the position
to a possible interim and the salary
that she demanded was so high that we
just couldn't afford to pay that
our other staff employees as many
organizations are trying to do we're
trying to hire Young new people give
them a chance and so our other staff
employees our first year employees and
they really do not possess at this point
in their careers an education of
sufficient and of breadth and depth to
serve as a director even as an interim
um we were able to find a new director
very quickly this last time in less than
two months and the Board of Trustees is
very happy with our choice
in the meantime we have a um
bylaw and a Personnel policy says that
says the day day to day liaison between
the monthly board meetings can be the
chair of the Board of Trustees
um but we have always given our
directors contracts we've always decided
at the time of employment what their
term of office is going to be we just
can't always comply with
um if they choose to leave and until a
successor can be found so I'm asking you
to please give small towns like myself
the flexibility of or until a successor
is found
so that we can comply with rsas that's
certainly our intent all along
and if you have any questions I'll be
glad to answer them
thank you for the testimony uh
representative man triputi
thank you Mr chair my quick question to
you is the role of a librarian public
librarian
has it changed significantly not just
working with books and you know
libraries public libraries have become a
community center per se
so has that anything to do with being
able to hire replace
and have a tenure
um you are thank you for the question
and you are absolutely correct the role
of libraries has has changed
significantly rightly so
um and so
our library I can't speak for others in
the state but our libraries have always
our library has always tried to find
someone who has an a current MLS degree
someone that is up to date with the
practices and the protocols of operating
a library
um
perhaps that may and maybe that's one of
the reasons why it is difficult for our
library and others too to find that
person that has sufficient breadth and
knowledge to be a librarian I would not
recommend lowering your library
standards and and hiring somebody that
wasn't as qualified as your community
needed just to comply with the law
uh representative Powell thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so I'm looking at the the um
change to that the bill is proposing to
the current language
and the fact that
you have or I understand the change from
the and to the or
my understanding is that that this will
enable an interim librarian to be hired
my concerns the question that I have is
it see does this
does this language change still require
that the librarian Remain the current
librarian remain as an employee
until the success is appointed despite
the contract
that's what I'm trying to change I'm
trying to change that the librarian
would not have to stay in the current
position
the director that left due to a severe
Health Emergency could not possibly stay
in his current position so I'm asking
that it'd be changed so that the person
does not have to or cannot stay in that
position
um is is allowed to to leave and we are
still compliant with the law now if if
the committee
um would prefer it does I agree with you
that that and and or
uh Clause at the end gets a little murky
I definitely agree so if the committee
would prefer and you would feel it would
be cleaner to accomplish what I'm trying
to accomplish here we could simply
just stop we could say that last
sentence I won't read the first sentence
but the last sentence could be the
librarian shall be appointed by the
board of Library Trustees for a term of
office agreed to at the time of
employment period
and I would be happy to introduce that
Amendment
a follow-up question
um that's exactly what I have noted on
my um bill here okay so
um yes I I we please look into doing
that right I I would be happy to do that
I can go to up up to OLS this afternoon
and take care of that and bring you in
an amendment today
representative still have a question
representative power asked my question
oh foreign
we're all thinking alike representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair
um this is much like the previous bill
in that we're talking about in order of
succession
so I'm wondering would it be
it'll be harder than changing and tour
but would it be better to have uh this
paragraph include
some language about
an interim librarian that could be
someone on the staff I think that thank
you for the question I think that would
be making things much more complicated
some libraries don't have an assistant
director or or an interim director or
anything like that so that would might
be
um causing them then to hire someone
that could automatically move into that
position also the job descriptions and
the um are different for a director and
an interim or an assistant as well as
the qualifications our assistant
director does not need to have an MLs
degree so it might not be the best
um
a thing for her or the library for her
to automatically move into the the uh
directorship thank you
I think I think what we're talking about
just ending it after
um agreed to at the time of employment
period is probably a cleaner way to
handle it than trying to bring in
assistant directors and interims and all
of that just my opinion
thank you thank you for taking the
question
I'm over here behind the thing yeah I
would like that moved like to be in
front of you but um the uh you keep on
mentioning the word director
um but we're talking about Librarians
and so I'm just wondering about
um
if this is really an issue of
directorship or if this is a issue of
you have to have a librarian you can
only have one and therefore this person
is you know leaving the job and
therefore you can't you're you're not
able to hire another librarian so I
don't understand where the issue kind of
is lying can you clarify that I can
thank you thank you for the question so
this
um when it's talking about the librarian
in the statute it is talking about the
librarian director
okay the libraries have Library
directors they have assistant directors
they have youth Librarians and then they
have just Librarians that handle the
circulation desk this statute is talking
about
um the direct the library director
because the library director is the only
person that the Board of Trustees has
the authority to hire all other
employees of the library are hired by
the library director
thank you
seeing no more questions thank you
representative Harvey uh please do fill
out uh thanks I I will and um I I will
get that amendment to you
um today thank you
uh we have one pink card Marsha
McLaughlin
good morning thank you I'm Marcia
um I am the President of the New
Hampshire library trustees Association
and I am here in opposition to the um
bill as it is currently presented
I would say however that if
representative Harvey does intend to
make the modification amending this
dropping the language Beyond employment
we would be in support of it
perfect sounds like that's the end of
your testimony yes sir thank you very
much there are any questions
thank you thank you have a good day
seeing none close the hearing on House
Bill 72.
moving right along we will now open the
hearing
on House Bill 148.
and we are looking for Prime sponsor
Edwards
who I do not see in the room
John
yes yes representative manager uh
majority Mr chair thank you thank you
sir Mr chair if it pleases the chair I'd
be happy to introduce the bill if you'd
like
um
what we're going to do is we're going to
move past this one for right now and uh
I'll actually make a decision on that
afterwards uh let's continue
okay uh HP
the ministry
administrator do you mind I can't hear
you would you
would you no I can't do that the bill
has not been introduced um this the
prime sponsor is not here and quite
honestly I I kind of of the
thinking that if the prime sponsor can't
show up for her bill I
know oh he is
yeah I'm gonna say nobody's notified us
on that but uh okay
um Mr chair yes uh representative may I
respectfully interrupt and just note
that in the past if the prime sponsor
was not available for whatever reason
um one of us any one of us on the
committee would be happy to present the
bill in that person's stead as a
courtesy to the other representative
thanks yes I I am aware of that that has
been the practice on uh several of the
Committees I've been to also I kind of
prefer to have the prime sponsor here
um
if in fact he has is having a medical
emergency
and since we have the administrator in
the back of the room uh we'll make an
exception on this one for now uh we'll
allow uh representative majority to
introduce HB 148
.
foreign
thank you Mr chair and for the record
representative Jim majory representing
Rockingham District 23 Northampton and I
am here in the stead of Representative
Edwards to introduce House Bill 148 an
act to raise the minimum value of County
purchases of equipment or materials
which are subject to competitive bidding
and there ends my testimony
I like that very good thank you for your
testimony
foreign
okay uh we'd like to call up uh Derek
ferland
probably hear me now okay thank you my
name is Derek Ferlin I'm the County
Manager for Sullivan County uh
testifying in support of this bill uh
unexpectedly someone from the bullpen um
because uh this bill although I was not
aware it was submitted until I Was
preparing for the other bills that I'll
be testifying later today uh certainly
in favor of it because in theory it's uh
simply updating a threshold that appears
to last have been updated either in 1998
or 1979 so I think it's just a simple
matter of keeping up with the times and
adjusting for inflation and I think
going from five thousand to ten thousand
is not an unreasonable increase to the
limit in fact it's in line with
thresholds currently in practice at
governor and Council for contracts that
they approve so I think it's a common
sense adjustment given the times and
hope you agree
representative Manchester
thank you Mr chair
um won't this
set a cascading effect for other
counties that
currently have this threshold and if one
County changes it won't that have a
trickling effect on other counties
my understanding is the changes to RSA
28 8 and so it repeals
288-ft which is the specific Rockingham
County so yes 288 does apply to all 10
counties
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman isn't there a
conflict in that actually in addition to
increasing the amount that section one
of the uh Amendment are the article says
the provisions in this sections shall
apply to all counties of the state and
yet we still have Hillsborough County
that has a a different uh procedure how
do we uh keep uh say that this is a this
applies to all counties in the state and
still have Hillsborough County separate
I am probably not in a great position to
speak to that since I'm from Sullivan
County but it does appear as though
there is an allowance to change 28 8-e
which is the Hillsborough County
specific statute so I would say as long
as there's Clarity and consistency then
that would be a good thing and however
that's achieved would be would make
sense to me follow up Mr chairman if I
you know you know in thank you Mr
chairman uh do you know whether or not
the petitioner representative Edwards
would be agreeable to deleting Section 3
in this bill the competitive bid in in
Hillsborough County
do you know if he's being I I do not I
do not all right thank you thank you Mr
chair representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this committee has
customarily
um been hesitant to make changes in the
rsas that apply to all counties in the
state for obvious reasons
and so my problem has to do with uh
lines four through five
uh if if you have
bylaws in
Sullivan County that allow you to make
these changes you could easily make
these changes without
forcing all of the counties in the state
to do what you're doing
so I I guess my question is would you be
amenable to amending the bill to remove
the reference to all counties in the
state
oh thanks for the question again I think
that's probably best answered by the
sponsor I just I'd be way in over my
head if I were to try to speak on on his
behalf I will say though that we have a
a purchasing and procurement policy that
does go beyond the RSA again just
speaking for Sullivan County only and
even with the five thousand dollar
threshold as currently written we
actually have subordinate procedures
where we require at least three quotes
for purchases above three thousand
dollars and Below five thousand and So
Below three thousand is where we can
just do sole source purchasing and I
would expect that we would amend our
purchasing and procurement policy
accordingly if this threshold is raised
so this just simply sets the upper limit
where it says you have to go out to bid
and uh just with the cost of materials
and other Commodities that we commonly
have to purchase today it just is a
um an added layer that I think given the
you know when this was originally
adopted again whether it was 98 or 1979
I think it's appropriate to evaluate
whether that's the correct limit
thank you for your testimony um I'm just
going to say that uh the the lack of the
ability to actually question the the
maker of the bill is the reason why I
hesitated to even bring it up because I
have numerous questions for uh
representative Edwards that we cannot
get answers to right now so uh for the
time being I'm going to close the
hearing on uh one HB 148
okay we will open the hearing on House
Bill 36 relative to fees of sheriffs and
Deputy sheriffs and I believe
representative fellows will be speaking
to this and introducing it
I can still say good morning uh chairman
turcotte and committee members I'm Sally
fellows I represent Plymouth Ashland and
holderness
and
I I see this as pretty much a
housekeeping bill
there the a law was passed
two years ago to allow the fees related
to Sheriff's Services
um
instead of being as instead of being a
fixed amount written into statute which
it was two years ago now it it can be
um the the sheriffs can make an
adjustment to those fees based on
inflation
and it it came to my attention when I
worked with the county delegation last
year that people
saw different ways to interpret the way
that measure of inflation was defined in
statute so what I did is I got together
with the sheriffs and we're all on the
same page that we can use this new
language to Define inflation
so it's the inflation rate is will be
and and the change in the annual
inflation rate from one year to the next
and this has doesn't change the part of
the statute that makes it optional it
just says it changes the way inflation
is measured
thank you for the testimony are there
any questions
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question so
my question is um with regards to
the reference to the CPI for all Urban
consumers specifically the Northeast
region and I did go to the website and
and looked at the different charts and
information there my question is
is it why is the Northeast region
selected and is there um
a metric specific or an average
specifically for the State of New
Hampshire
so I'll share this graphs with you
so so this build does not change
um that part that you just asked about
the that it references the Northeast
consumer price index that was there
before but to answer your question there
is not one for specifically for New
Hampshire there are many different
um areas there are also different cpis
some of them for example
um
education funding in the adequacy aid
formula uses change to this annual
change to the CPI
for all Urban excluding medical expenses
so there are many different cpis
and
one of the things that this bill does
well is clarify
exactly what is meant by changing the
CPI so it's specifically with the
amendment it's specifically refers to
the annual and you can see on this chart
this is just I put a note at the bottom
but this chart is exactly what you get
when you go to the Internet and look it
up if you're actually getting the CPI
that um
references that's referenced in statute
and some people one of the common
confusions
is the difference between the annual CPI
change and a 12-month CPI change
annual is based on what the CPI was for
all 12 months of the year
and sometimes you hear on the news
they'll refer to a 12-month change in
the CPI and that is just looking at two
data points it for example it would look
at the CPI number in
uh July of one year in July of the next
and using the annual is better
because things can be volatile for one
from one month to the next as you saw
during the last year the price of gas
you know went up and then it came down
again so that's one of the components of
the CPI so it's better to use annual it
Smooths it out so you don't get peaks in
if you know it's actually technically
possible that you could actually have a
negative
are there any other questions
representative lasalles
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
for taking my question
do you know the last time that these
fees that we're talking about were
raised
um this this bill has been in effect the
bill that passed two years ago
only only came to be used just this past
year
on the count in it so it would be the
county budget and the sheriff's fees
that were done sometime during 2022.
and um maybe somebody else who I don't I
don't know how long it had been before
that so maybe somebody else might be
able to tell you
thank you
are there any other questions
I believe I have one let me just uh
in a single sentence could you
state
why this change is needed
because it was in different people
interpreted it differently
and
um it wasn't always interpreted as even
an a 12-month change it wasn't
interpreted as sometimes not as even as
a 12-month change so that's one of the
reasons I took out that reference to
June
um because that was part of the
confusion and I just changed it to
annual
for the year calendar year so there
would be no confusion and using
um the the timing works fine
in terms of using
um
calendar year
okay thank you very much
any other questions representative
thank you Mr chair so this clarifies
because the budget cycle is June I can't
I said this clarifies because the county
budget runs from June end of June to you
know beginning of uh my my understanding
is that the counties are not the same
some run on a calendar year some run on
a um
you know July to June so using this
annual one I think will work pretty well
because from what I could see when I
looked on the internet the ones who use
a calendar year actually don't seem to
be voting on their budget until March
kind of like towns some towns do so I
think the timing will work
well
okay thank you
for the questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
you're welcome
okay
next uh representative schuit
good morning or I guess it's good
afternoon now
uh my name is Diane schuett
I represent Merrimack 12 the town of
Pembroke and I am co-sponsored this bill
and I'm appearing before you today as
chair of the Merrimack County delegation
and would just appeal to you all as
members of your respective County
delegations that this small correction
is important for the budget work in each
of your respective counties
uh there are a few sheriffs of hearing
before you also who can describe the
effects of this a little change on their
specific departments and I hope that you
will all support passage of this uh I
would say to representative lascelles
that the last
increase was 2010.
thank you
chairman
that that does complete your testimony
yes very good representative lasalles
thank you for taking my question
the nature of the my question with
respect to the last time those fees were
set
in effect
applying a an inflation Factor
to the base which was set in 2010
will it not have the effect of
perpetuating a lower fee
because even though now we would have an
inflation factor that keeps up with
current inflation
the difference between
2010 and today's prices
will not be affected because we're
basing it on 2010.
does that make sense to you
um not exactly and I I will admit that
representative fellows is the math
person who uh perfected this idea and
again I think the sheriffs behind me who
each represent a different County can
tell you the effect that it will have on
their specific budgets
thank you
represent uh yokella
thank you and thank you for taking the
question hi
um
as the
um chair of your delegation when is the
first time that you're seeing the
um that you would be proposed a number
um
um and is your delegation on the um
on the fiscal or the the calendar year
um we're on the uh the June cycle yeah
Sheriff Croft my particular sheriff is
here and can probably give you some
details on that we've just started we
just formed our budget subcommittees uh
Tuesday of this week so we're just
beginning our budget work for Merrimack
County
and we hope to have a full budget
proposal available to most of our towns
V4 town meeting week in March
seeing no more hands race thank you
representative I'm sorry I said I see no
more hands raised thank you
representative thank you very much
uh last pink card that we have uh
Sheriff William Wright
foreign
good morning
chairman turcotten members of the
committee I appreciate you hearing me
today my name is Bill Wright I'm the
sheriff of Belknap County I'm currently
in my second term I have over 24 years
of law enforcement service here in the
state of New Hampshire
and um I'm here to testify and support a
house bill 36 on behalf of the New
Hampshire Sheriff's Association
I'll have Sheriff Stiegler introduce
himself and then we can go forward with
uh testimony okay
good morning Mr chair and
representatives thank you for having us
here today my name is Jeff Stiegler I'm
the elected Sheriff um just started my
third term in Grafton County I'm the
vice president of the New Hampshire
Sheriff's Association on behalf of our
president Dominic riccardi from Carroll
County he had an unexpected issue come
up this morning and we're obviously here
in his um in his place and I'll let
Sheriff Wright who has provided some
written testimony uh lead off but I have
might have a little bit more historical
knowledge to uh to this matter as we go
forward
back uh this past summer uh
representative fellows had approached
the sheriff's Association to discuss the
matter with
um what we're here to discuss today uh
with the CPI and uh the sheriffs had
discussed how we uh bill out how the law
read and we were in agreement that uh
there should be some adjustments as a
house cleaning uh process
um 2010 was the last time that the fees
were increased that we're aware of in
last year we had attempted to fix some
of that but of course when we uh that
was through Senate Bill 77
we found that there was a house cleaning
uh section that needed to be fixed and
that's why we're here today
um
we do not
um I I'm a believer that with the
services that we provide when it comes
to uh civil process uh we're not
collecting uh exactly what is
necessarily being spent out
um to do the services so this will just
help uh offset uh the costs that are
associated with doing the job as we know
gas prices went up uh you know printing
paper Printing on paper went up paper
went up
um all that stuff so we're just trying
to capture a little more revenue on that
end in order for us to
um provide a better service for our
community
thank you for your testimony any
questions
seeing that and I actually have a couple
for you guys
um
I'm noting in the language that uh
representative schuett mentioned that
the last increase was in 2020 or
something
am I understanding the language
correctly it says that uh it the fees
may be increased annually
and it has to be approved by the vote of
the County Convention so
even if and I'm not saying that this is
what we should do I'm just saying that
even if this is approved it still puts
the ultimate Authority for raising fees
in the hands of the County Convention
because the word is May
and
says by a vote of the County Convention
so I'm understanding that correctly
you are sir every uh County Sheriff
would work with their commission and
County Administrator to prepare
correspondence for the delegation this
is what I did last year and I want to
put for the record I'm very thankful
that representative fellows caught this
given her background in this area of
finance and pointed this out and kind of
came to us to uh
because this piece was not known to us
in the Bill about the one percent
increase for the month of June we just
saw that in the end that this is great
they're raising the fees we didn't want
to go too far we didn't want to go too
little and all of a sudden the bill came
back with that Amendment on it uh that
brought up this one percent but perhaps
there wasn't enough discussion and study
with respect to that and she brought
this to the Forefront and this is why
we're here today all 10 sheriffs I can
speak for unanimously agree that there
needs to be a better mechanism for
raising these rates that is because a
sheriff Wright testified it does help
offset our revenues
um certainly Revenue goes up when the
economy is not doing so well and
inflation is high revenues go down when
things are more streamlined but a big
piece that I think also needs to be here
for the record is obviously we want to
make sure our employees are being paid
fairly competitively and their their
benefits are you know in the same boat
so we're not losing them and of course
those things are voted on by the county
delegation at the end of the budget
cycle and these things have a
significant cost factor to them that
none of us as managers like to see but
we know that it's there's a purpose for
it and it's it's a good thing so we
certainly don't bill out the way no
offense to anybody that's a member of
the New Hampshire bar but a lawyer's
office is going to bill you for all of
those billable hours that they do and we
just simply have a fee structure to help
offset these costs that are otherwise
inherited by those of all of us the
taxpayers
thank you totally understood uh follow
up
actually uh representative Manchester
thank you Mr chair sitting on our
executive County Executive Board I
understand so this is going to help
annual adjustment of the fee that will
reflect what the
fee or the CPI was based on the annual
uh changes correct you are absolutely
correct it is the only mechanism I've
yet to hear of that might be more uh
conducive if you will to rather than
just coming to the legislature every uh
every year to say could you raise that
another five dollars another five
dollars another five dollars and we had
waited 12 years before uh this this last
bill went through this might very well
be the way to stabilize this if you will
put more of a tourniquet on it um so
we're certainly hopeful that uh your
committee will uh stamp this is ought to
pass and thank you Mr chair thank you
quick follow-up a quick follow-up go
ahead yeah so will this
in your mind or this will still keep the
local control of the counties to be able
to adjust as they need it yes you're
you're correct the the county delegation
reserves the right to either reject or
accept the request that I send it to my
three Commissioners and obviously I want
their support as lobbyists for the
sheriff's budget if you will
um to represent um
they're good character as well as mine I
hope that the delegation would be
unanimous as the obviously the ultimate
goal and um that I think is the
objective for all of the other nine
sheriffs in the county but you folks uh
in your county duties that you do will
be the ones deciding on this if it's a
year where it should be raised or
perhaps shouldn't be raised
and I also believe that this will be
more reflective of actually what's going
on in the economy at that given time
rather than just coming in with a one
percent uh that doesn't cover costs or
or maybe it over covers costs so this
gives that ability to actually take that
totality of it say this is act you know
this year maybe we go up five percent
next year we go down five percent we
don't know uh but at least we have a
better picture of of how it's working
thank you representative uh Yokel
thank you and thank you for taking the
question
um it's kind of a two-part question
um
in reference to this the uh my question
before when do you guys start
um drafting your budgets
um and
um
you kept mentioning the um one percent
um but there is no language in the
current law or in the proposed law about
one percent so I was just
um wanted to give you an opportunity to
explain where where that was coming from
with respect to budget preparation my
understanding is six of our counties out
of the ten are on fiscal years and four
are on calendar years so preparation is
different
um mine is starting uh matter of fact
it's on my calendar at the beginning of
February that's how early we get going
to get to our commissioner's piece and
then the executive committee's piece so
they'll have some time to ingest all
this and and work with us on these
matters uh with respect to your other
question as I thought I had alluded to
in my testimony before that one percent
piece just kind of came out of nowhere
to us it came from somewhere uh in the
initial uh increase in the bills
um
uh Resurrection if you will from 2010
when they increased it and we looked at
the bottom and said what is this one
percent in June you know how does this
how does this work and obviously with
the prices of everything going up I
certainly prepared a letter for my uh
Commissioners and delegation asking for
the support and that's how we got to to
where we are and representative fellows
uh stepped in and said I really need to
meet with all your sheriffs to discuss
this and educate all of you a little
better and how the inflation pieces
piece works
any further questions uh representative
thank you Mr chair and thanks for coming
today both of you and sharing
information my question is in regards to
the CPI and I'm wondering if before this
all conversation came about
either one of you or both of you
understood what the CPI is and where it
comes from
well as representative fellows testified
there were many different cpis but CPI
as I understand it from being a
collective bargaining president in my
previous career
um is Consumer Price Index Northeast is
really what it what it comes down to and
what is the
um
that rate that's going to be set for
that for that year and it's one of those
things that's usually set as kind of the
the center of you know where we're going
and where we want to be great thank you
thank you
seeing no more hands thank you gentlemen
for your testimony representative
fellows if you could take come back up
for one second please thank you
thank you for having us
thank you
um
representative power brought it up in
her questions uh regarding the Consumer
Price Index and
um the website that she went to as well
as I did and as she mentioned there's
many many many different things so here
you won't need that I don't think my
only point was
um
on your chart that you gave out it says
CPI for all Urban consumers and then it
says down below series all items
Northeast Urban when I looked at the
website
um
I kind of jotted down that I think on
line six it would be helpful if it said
Consumer Price Index all items for the
urban consumers because it is there are
if you leave if you just say com
consumer price index that can be
interpreted a lot of ways and where your
chart your chart does basically what I
believe
you should do to make this uh the best
spill it can so by simply adding the
words all items behind the words
Consumer Price Index I think that might
be a nice Improvement
um I I understand what you're saying
what the reason that I use those words
are those exact those are match the
words that are on here which are the
words that the um
the Labor Statistics uses and what I
will point to again it says if you go
down
um
under where it says series
oh okay it says all items oh okay you
know I'd be fine with that because if
you don't do that it leaves open to
interpretation uh you know is it the
consumer right uh consumer index less
medical is it the consumer index less
fuel you know that kind of stuff so if
you just put the all items in there I
think that would be a a good
clarification yeah on line six at the
beginning of line six put in all items
or maybe between five and six increase
in after the words all items in the
Consumer Price Index yeah that I I think
that that would be fine in I don't think
it would be
um
anyone would interpret that differently
correct I just want to share with you
that I don't want to share this it's a
draft but what I did for
um that can be shared with the municipal
Association and and anybody who's
interested is like three pages of
exactly how you go and find it
because
they're you can end up in different
places and unless you're really familiar
with it you may be looking at something
different for example there's there's
this is Northeast Consumer Price Index
there's actually a New England price
index so if you weren't
you know really nitpicking the words you
could easily confuse those two so and
ultimately it will still be under the
purview of the county delegation to give
the final Authority anyway so but I just
think adding that would yeah do you
would you like me to draft something I
would okay I'll do that fine
I don't see
um
did we I just wanted to apologize to the
chair and the committee of referencing
my Sheriff who was here to testify but
due to the lateness of your beginning he
had another obligation and had to leave
oh that's so sorry for misleading you no
it's fine okay I see no more cards or
comments on this
so I will close the hearing on HB 36 we
are actually back on schedule
um so we will uh
return here at 1 30 to start our
afternoon of bills with representative
Aarons
um thank you all for coming
we're gonna get roll in here we're going
to start open up the
House Bill 41 relative to public notice
of meetings for County conventions
representative Aaron you have the floor
this afternoon
good afternoon thank you Mr chair and
thank you members of Municipal County
for hearing this bill and subsequent
ones which I will be introducing
so I'm bringing to you today house bill
41.
and this bill changes County Convention
meeting notice requirements and require
seven days notice of supplemental
appropriation public hearings to be
published in a daily newspaper
the current County statute seems to be
in conflict with other parts of Statute
and the point of this legislation is to
fix that and clean do some cleaning up
in in statutes so that things match
for our County Convention a few months
ago in deciding about bonding there was
much confusion about how to notice the
meeting properly because of the
conflicting statutes
the bond attorney told us not to go by
the 91a requirements
and um
Sullivan County Manager Derek furland
behind me here will explain further some
of the confusion that that was met with
that I know other
um Counties have also had similar
concerns with what part of Statute they
needed to follow with regard to noticing
meetings
so the first part of this bill repealing
RSA 24 not colon 9--d
that's because it's in direct
contradiction to RSA 91-a colon 2.
the County Convention quote unquote is
the name for the legislative body of a
county and according to 91a colon 1 dash
a
V1 section d
the quote legislative body of a County
is included in an indefinition different
definition of a public body and should
therefore follow the guideline the
guidance in RSA 91a unless specific
instances require special meeting notice
procedures
examples of these specific instances
include public hearings for County bonds
as per RSA 33 colon 10. as well as
supplemental Appropriations as per RSA
24 colon 14-a if the suggestion above is
implemented
furthermore the rationale for only
noticing meetings for two days if the
general court is in session isn't really
clear as to why that would make a
difference and appears to be outdated
therefore the recommendation is would be
to change make this change in the
language and the second part changing
the language in 24 colon 14a this
clarifies the noticing requirements for
public hearings associated with
supplemental Appropriations and the
verbiage matches the public hearing
language in RSA 33 colon 10 for Co for
County bonds
so it's pretty much trying to what we
want to do is is match up the
noticing requirements uh seven days
versus 24 hours
and uh
and that's
what this is
thank you
thank you for the testimony
um do you have any written testimony
that you'll be submitting or I just have
you know what I read to you right now
I'd be happy to hand that in I can do
that electronically if that helps you
better and I'll do that when I get home
if you could that'd be great sure any
questions representative ninja putty
thank you Mr chair
um
have in some communities there you know
you talk about the newspaper circulation
some communities have no newspaper
that's on a daily basis so what we get
is seven day old or
you know so how do you reconcile the
fact that
not every Community has a daily
newspaper to advertise
uh well as far as I understand
[Music]
um
you know we could make
changes to reflect you know more current
that if it's on someone's website
or you know update the statute further
to reflect the fact that um you know
people don't rely on newspapers anymore
Representatives Davis
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um in 2018 this Committee in fact passed
a bill that dealt with that specific
issue and I'm I'm wondering if you might
want to take a look at it and consider
adding some of the language in it it is
New Hampshire RSA 675 colon 7.
and uh it's under the requirements for
public hearing
and it's it mentions daily newspapers
but it also mentions websites where the
information needs to be posted on a
website and for how long there's we we
spent a long time on this bill
and we felt that we had covered all the
bases it was bipartisan Bill supported
by pretty much everyone
um so I just I offer that as a as a
question as if you might want to take a
look at that and consider using some of
that language too thank you very much
what was the RSA number again 675 colon
1.
okay thank you I will take a look at
that thank you
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative so my
question pertains to
um
the first part uh the first section of
the this bill line one my marked up copy
did does not have line numbers so I
apologize so specifically it's um with
regard to the repealing that section and
so 24 colon 9--d pertains to the notice
of
the um meeting of the convention or the
delegation
so why is that being repealed it's not
being repealed entirely it's being
replaced rep well yeah repealed and
reenacted
um so 24 colon 9--d would read notice
period unless otherwise specified
meetings shall be noticed in accordance
with RSA 91 colon a uh Dash a colon 2.
so it's
the the that whole section is not being
totally struck
a follow-up thank you Mr chair I and I
wasn't able to
um get my whole question out I'm sorry
so um I understand that
and my I could you please explain the
necessity to repeal and replace thereby
following RSA
91-8 colon 2 what is insufficient with
regard to the provision under the
section of our New Hampshire statutes
Title II counties
regarding the notice of
County delegations
what is insufficient with that section
that that has to be repealed and
reenacted in a pointer pointing towards
91a thank you
because we're matching up we're we're
taking out the seven day
um
the seven day notice and matching it
with what 91 a recommends as specified
that because
the um
because the County Convention is a
legislative body
just like what is pointed to in 91a
so
are there any further questions
seeing no more thank you representative
Aaron we will see you in a few minutes
yep
uh next we have Derek ferland
two of these oops
uh thank you Mr chair and once again uh
members of the committee uh Derek Ferlin
Sullivan County Manager uh testifying
here in support of of house bill 41. I
don't have much to add
um from representative Aaron's uh
thorough introduction of the bill just
to Simply reiterate that this is purely
a matter of of consistency
with the various references to the
required notice for a delegation meeting
so what this does is
um when the matters of public hearing
related to Appropriations whether it's a
supplemental appropriation in 2414 or a
bond hearing in accordance with RSA 3310
that it's
um just consistent that there's a seven
day notice for those actions whereas a
quote unquote standard delegation
meeting would simply comply with 91a so
it's just a little bit cleaner I think
and more consistent I would also point
out that in the supplemental
appropriation section which is 24
14-a prior to this suggested change
there was no reference to a required
noticing period so again just
consistency across the board that when
it's a public hearing relative to
Appropriations now it's seven days
across the board otherwise it would just
be 24 hours in accordance with 91a
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you
we do not have any more pink cards up
here is there anybody else who had
wished to testify on this bill
okay seeing none we'll close the hearing
on HP 41 HP 43 will be up in just a few
moments
thank you
just a reminder everybody in the room
when we are in between bills we are
still on being recorded just for for
your information whether or not
you care about that or not but we are
being recorded So
okay it is a 1 45 open up the hearing on
HB 30 uh 43
relative to County Commissioners custody
and care of all property
representative Aaron you're up
okay
um so this is uh HB 43 an act relative
to County Commissioners custody and care
of all property
this bill removes references to
ratifications by the County Convention
and renders the custody and care of all
property belonging to the county to the
County Commissioners
as per specified in 28 colon 4.
28 colon 4 reads
custody of property under County
Commissioners the county commissioner
shall have the custody and care of all
property belonging to the county
period
so
accordingly
should they not be required to get
subsequent approval from the delegation
in performing one of their functions
this is an executive branch of the
government
this also links 28 colon 8--d and 28
colon 8-a for the threshold where
competitive bidding that is required for
uh
acquisition or property
the thought here
is that since RSA 28 colon 4 places
custody and care of all property
belonging to the county squarely in the
hands of County Commissioners
based on RSA 28 colon 4 they shouldn't
require subsequent approval from the
delegation for various transactions
County Commissioners are also elected by
the people to make decisions regarding
custody and care of County Land
that is one of their functions
if they require oversight then shouldn't
that come directly from their
constituents
the County Commissioners already are
bound by what they are budgeted and that
is a financial oversight that the county
delegation should have
within that budget shouldn't the County
Commissioners be able to make decisions
in the best interest of the county as
they are directed to
nrsa 28 colon 4 regarding custody and
care of property
the other argument is with regard to
competitive bidding
many times competitive bids move faster
than it is possible to arrange to
convene a County Convention delegation
and or EFC meeting executive finance
committee meeting
many good deals benefiting the taxpayer
might be lost or to have been lost if
the ratification cannot be obtained in a
timely manner
and that's been a problem I guess for
some of the counties
so um that's all I want to say basically
on this particular bill I would defer
any other
comments regarding the bill to a County
Commission a County Manager Derek
ferland from Sullivan County behind me
thank you representative am I
understanding that you would prefer not
to take questions I would be happy to
field question sure just making sure
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
again for taking my question
so
I just want to ask a question about that
kind of the whole panoply of Sullivan
County bills that are coming before us
and I just wanted to ask if Sullivan
County has bylaws
that govern its operations I don't know
that they do I know they have
um
they have their own set of rules which
they operate
more and more counties in New Hampshire
are adopting bylaws that empower the
Commissioners and the the delegation to
do to conduct The Daily Business of the
of County government without having to
come before the legislature and and do
this tedious thing of
slightly amending a bill here and a bill
there and I wondered if that might be
down the road a solution to some of the
issues that are facing you because
traditionally in this committee
we are reluctant to
to rule on matters that affect one
County or a problem that one county is
having but it's not being experienced by
other counties and by changing the
overall
statute
that that change is going to perhaps
cause Downstream problems for other
counties so we have traditionally kind
of aired on the side of wanting
County government to be
um
not affected by the individual
day-to-day happenings of any particular
County and so that's why I'm just
recommending
thinking about adopting bylaws that
would allow you to do all of these
things that you you need to do
understood
thank you thank you
are there any questions for
representative
thank you and thank you for taking the
question
um
when you're referencing the the
um other part of the law that says that
they are kind of stewards of the
property
um well why do you or what what language
in there leads you to believe that they
should be able to dispose of the
property without oversight
well custody and care of all property
wouldn't that include disposition as
well not necessarily
thank you are there any other questions
before you leave representative I have a
couple questions for you please
um first one is in your opinion would
this eliminate the oversight and in some
regards transparency
or the county delegation
I don't think so I the county delegation
would still know what is going going on
or what the plans are I would imagine I
don't know that this would
um you know remove any kind of
transparency
okay thank you
um
is there a
looking at the the RSA and the the bill
is there a Dollar limitation on say the
sales of real property in other words if
it was
two hundred dollars or ten thousand
dollars or ten million dollars or a
hundred million dollars
would
this let's just use the 100 million
dollar property without the existing
language
would that hundred million dollar
property be able to be sold on be by the
by a vote of the County Commissioners
without oversight
possibly I don't know I would defer that
question to uh
to my County Manager thank you thank you
for the questions Josh uh representative
uh yokella thank you and thank you for
taking uh this question you you uh were
talking about how
um you know having this oversight
um and needing the
um delegation to approve of
um
um the sale of this information would
not be timely because of the notice
requirements and stuff like that but in
the previous bill you seek to
change the seven day requirement to 24
hours and so
thing
do you believe that 24 hours is not
enough
um
time frame for
the oversight to occur
well this particular Bill assumes the
statute remains how it is now
I mean you know in terms of noticing
requirements
it
the bill is by itself
thank you
are there any further questions uh
representative Manchester
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
counties typically have a lot of
buildings and property
that's their asset
to not have the county delegation
oversee representative Manchester is
there a question yes so let's just let's
suspend for a moment let's one of the
issues that I want to be very clear of
I've already mentioned once today is let
in this committee let's keep our
comments to questions of inquiry as much
as possible I understand there are times
where you're going to have to do a
little bit of a lead-in but let's keep
it as much as we can to questions
clarifying testimony thank you thank you
Mr chair I'll try to would this not take
away the local control and the working
of
the delegation body the county
delegation and the Commissioners who are
duly elected but
not have that working relationship
giving power to one
body of elected
I think it strengthens the
uh the original
the RSA 28 colon 4
that says County Commissioners shall
have the custody and care of all
property belonging to the county
so it gives them the powers which were
vested by this particular RSA
are there any further questions
thank you representative Aaron thank you
we had two pink cards filled out on HB
41 was one of those
it's supposed to be 43
for you
all right why don't you come up in test
five and fill out another one because it
was filled out as HB 41.
come on up
thanks again Mr chair and members of the
committee
um once again Derek Ferrell and Sullivan
County Manager testifying in support of
House Bill 43. uh
I'd like to begin with just a brief
background
um
as to why I'm here for all six of these
bills I was appointed to my position in
March of 2017. uh prior to that I was a
career officer in the United States Air
Force and uh retired as a colonelin
earlier in 2017 and so I say that to say
I understand
um regulations they really matter
um and when I got into my current job I
really have relied on the rsas as the
Bible to help me learn about my current
position current duties and so over the
course of the last nearly six years I've
just come across in the course of of
Performing my duties things that I
observed were either inconsistent or
unclear or contradictory and so these
bills were really an effort to uh to
clean that up now to Representatives
Davis's previous question about bylaws
uh no we don't have bylaws specifically
we do have policies that address issues
that are either not quite covered or
when we are more restrictive than the
rsas but by and large we just tend to
rely on the rsas to order to avoid being
redundant and running risk of of
operating outside the law so
um
House Bill 43 really initially stemmed
from my research into the disposal of
County property which uh I don't want to
butcher your name representative is it
yokella okay
um and that was a there's a 300
threshold for that which we'll get to in
a subsequent hearing and so when I was
looking at the other applicable
references that's where I focused in on
the word custody
and then I was like well what does
custody really mean and I think it kind
of gets to your point words matter as we
all know and I can appreciate too that
some of the the some of these bills that
are submitted you have to be equal parts
uh historian English major or uh
attorney and unfortunately I am neither
one of those uh I was an engineer but
that seemed neither here nor there so I
think really the root cause and maybe
some of the concern that this could
provide the appearance that we're uh the
executive branches is eroding some of
the authority of the legislative branch
by uh reducing oversight and I just
assure you that is that was never the
intention
um but I do think if you're going to do
a root cause analysis there's four terms
that I think need to be clarified and
and maybe the addition of a definition
section would provide that legislative
intent and avoid any potential
misunderstandings and those four terms
are custody real estate real property
and personal property because they all
appear in the rsas both in chapter 24
which is the county convention chapter
and chapter 28 which is the
commissioner's chapter I thought it was
interesting just trying to you know make
my own determination of what was the
legislative intent vis-a-vis the the two
branches of government and how they
would work together for these matters
um I found it interesting that the word
property does not appear in chapter 24
at all real estate appears twice and it
clearly provides the Authority for the
delegation to approve the purchase and
sale of real estate
real property property and personal
property are all contained in chapter 28
which is the commissioner's chapter
the problem that I see is that depending
on which source you use the definition
of real property sometimes can include
land which I think can very quickly be
confused with real estate and as well as
the more strict and I think rigid and I
think uh more appropriate definition
which is things that are on the land
that are immobile like buildings crops
uh dams roads
whether they're built or natural and
then that distinguishes from personal
property which are things that are
movable
so
in this case
I took a I guess legalistic view of the
word custody which
um
I I tend to mean full legal control to
include the ability to dispose of of
real property but that it does
distinguish real estate so
I hope that background was at least
somewhat useful I do think if you look
at various case studies so what's a for
instance a for instance would be last
year we had a Timber Harvest on one of
our plots of land so to me Timber is
Real Property by the definition that I
found online we did not go to the
delegation for approval to dispose of
that real property because it was just
run through our natural resources
department if we were to sell or lease a
parcel of land uh real estate then those
all those actions we we actually review
our leases annually with the delegation
uh in conjunction with our budget
approval process if we were to sell a
building so the building is real
property
but it's sitting on land it would be
impossible for the Commissioners to sell
the building without also addressing uh
the status the legal status of the land
under it so I think there'd be plenty of
opportunity and oversight and
collaboration between the two branches
of government with respect to uh this
RSA
so 28 8C
which is on the competitive bidding on
sales and leases of real property
again just getting back to just making a
distinction between what is considered
real property versus what is real estate
and looking back at how those terms are
used both in chapters 24 and 28.
um
and then on 28 8D section one
the use of real property again we have a
one facility in our Unity campus that's
been
um we've had in the past allowed the
public to use it for events and it's
just rented out at a nominal you know
fifty dollar fee which is basically the
the security deposit to prevent from any
damages
um
that sort of arrangement has always been
traditionally the purview of the
Commissioners and if we had to go to the
delegation every time we wanted to have
somebody have a birthday party um in
that building that again that'd be
pretty unwieldy and just appreciating
the extra time that it takes to uh to
convene a delegation and that's pretty
hard in Sullivan we only have 13 uh reps
some of the other counties I would
imagine it'd be very very difficult
indeed so
um I think there's any
possible addition that might help clear
up some of this confusion it would just
be simply to add a definition section
and make it Crystal Clear what the
legislative intent is and really
distinguish between real estate real
property
um personal property and then as well as
the concept of what does custody truly
entail again because depending on the
source you can find varying degrees of
definition that you know there's a bit
of a spectrum it's not like there's a
you know a black and white definition
for every one of these terms but
just observations that I've come across
in the last five years and it's again I
can appreciate it's between the the
historical aspect of some of these rsas
some of which date back to the early
1900s or even earlier
um
or the you know what is what do the
words mean and then there's the the
English major that I'm not or the
attorney
um how would you how would you legally
interpret these in in court and again I
don't have any experience with that
either unfortunately
thank you
okay thank you for the testimony
questions representative stavis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking yet another question
you may have said this uh the sponsor
may have said this and I apologize if I
missed it but with this bill as with the
others is there some substantive
material problem that you are attempting
to fix other than perhaps some
inconsistency in the rsas is there some
tangible issue that Sullivan County is
facing but by making these changes to
the rsas it will fix that problem
in terms of approximate cause no the
answer is no it's just it's simply
housekeeping it's if we don't do it now
eventually when it does become there
might be a situation down the road
whether it's in Sullivan or the other
nine counties it's just simply in the
better the greater interest in the
greater good to make sure that our rsas
are as clean and consistent and accurate
as possible for whether it's today or
sometime down the road
representative Elbert
thank you for taking my question
commissioner
[Music]
um
is RSA 28 colon 6 a uh the definition of
competitive bidding it's statutorily
defined but I don't
know if that's what's being referenced
here
I'm sorry representative Albert Albert
was at 28 6A yes line five
it says competitive bidding
or in accordance with 28 colon 6 Dash a
is
is that different from competitive
bidding that is statutorily defined I'm
sorry I don't have that
what's the difference between
competitive bidding
or in accordance with 28 colon 6-a
you said line five what which was the
original reference I I see 28 6A but you
started somewhere else I'm just 28 6A
okay is what what is that
that is the authority to contract for
professional Real Estate Services
okay
so competitive bidding is defined
somewhere I ran across it it
open competitive bidding for example
so if you have
a sale or a lease of real property and
you've accepted bids
I don't see where there's a
urgency regarding time to to bring that
to the
commissioner delegation for ratification
[Music]
you mentioned that you know or
mentioned that
you know sometimes things go really fast
and but if you've
complied with the competitive bidding
requirement for the states
where you have to publish then you have
to accept the sealed bids and then it
goes to you know a meeting and they open
the bids and someone's awarded
why would that
I mean the commission the delegation
meets quarterly
I think yeah
and I don't understand what the time
constraint is on on
that would would make it necessarily to
take the power out of the delegation's
hands and and put it strictly with the
commissioners
uh well it's it's quarterly and
there's a lot of that happens in between
that quarter
um could it be scheduled and
synchronized
um sure then I think really now the
issue gets back to what does the word
custody mean and that I think that's you
know maybe the other issue is is uh how
much Authority do the Commissioners have
when we say they have custody and
control over over real property
um then we have to agree on what the
definition of custody means so it's
really two parts it's the is it
convenient
um
and then do we agree on the the
definition of the word custody okay
thank you
just a
um representative got three and one
second just a reminder representative
Elward in the future
um after you ask a question a question
and it's been answered just uh request a
follow-up question rather than having a
back and forth discussion
thank you very much Adam Guthrie uh if
this would pass
thank you for taking my question thank
you Mr chairman uh if this would pass
would would it not take the authority of
the executive committee and the uh the
uh delegation
wouldn't take their Authority out of the
loop as far as any purchase or sale of
property and we may decide what property
is but wouldn't wouldn't not take that
Authority away
uh thanks for the question
representative I've got three I guess
that's really the Crux of the issue is
is what Authority
and what was the intent of the way the
rsas were written now as I said before
chapter 24 doesn't mention the word
property at all so if we infer from that
that the legislative branch I.E the
delegation was never really meant to be
custodians of the property and that
Authority was reserved for the
Commissioners as the executive branch
then I think we have to have a just a
dialogue about where the rules of the
road are regarding the two branches of
government and their respective you know
where does their Authority meet and
hopefully not overlap and if it does
overlap then it's in an acceptable
manner to both branches I mean that's I
didn't intend to provoke a uh branches
of government
um discussion but I do think those
discussions probably are you know
necessary from time to time you know
there's an evolutionary nature to these
rsas some of them which again they date
back to when we had County farms and
right now only Grafton County still has
a County farm so there's a lot in here
that has changed and so as we change
with it just out of the necessary uh
course of doing our County government
business I just think these are the
opportunities that come up and without
trying to create additional
administrative you know headaches to try
to you know change an apostrophe at a a
maybe a word choice change but I think
these are you know the relevant issues
and we should discuss them so that way
there's no misunderstandings on behalf
of the Commissioners and the appointed
staff and that we're not uh deemed to be
encroaching on the authority and
responsibility that's reserved for the
legislative branch if I'll follow up Mr
chairman absolutely Miss uh
representative Guthrie go ahead thank
you are you saying that if I'm a count
if I'm in a county and they we have a
building for sale
that it's not clear to you that the
executive committee and on the
delegation wants to have oversight on
that
I think Mr representative Guthrie I
think that's an entirely reasonable
assumption
um I can just speak from Sullivan
County's perspective I don't know when
we'll ever have a building for sale it
might happen someday but the building
won't be sold unless the real estate
under it is also part of that
transaction and the real estate in my
opinion is the trigger that's going to
necessitate and mandate
oversight from the delegation you can't
just sell the building without the
property or the land property here I am
mixing terms without the land under it
also being I would think part of that
transaction so I think that that's where
the two authorities I think they meet
perfectly together the real property is
the building the land under it is the
real estate the Commissioners have the
vertical component and the delegation is
responsible for the horizontal component
so they would both need to be in the
loop and on board with that transaction
thank you Mr chairman
representative Manchester
thank you Mr chair thank you
commissioner for taking my question
um is this solutions that's being looked
at exclusively for Sullivan County or
have you looked at how it's going to
impact other nine counties
I've had discussions with my my
counterparts not every county has a
county manager or administrator but
there's generally somebody who serves in
that capacity so at the New Hampshire
Association of counties for the past
several years we had a separate strategy
committee and one of the goals of that
strategy committee was to identify among
other things
opportunities to clarify the rsas so a
lot of this work that I observed from
just conducting my own business were
also issues that were discussed under
the auspices of the strategy committee
so there has been county-wide awareness
of these issues I wouldn't go so far as
to say that they've all signed on
because we didn't quite formally go
through that process so I'm not saying
they don't agree with it I can't say
that they disagree or agree
um so it that was the Clearinghouse
originally where we were hoping to get a
more formal New Hampshire Association of
County process to identify these issues
and then work with our respective state
representatives in our own counties to
get them submitted as bills but we never
quite got that far the strategy
committee has just for various reasons
not been able to uh to really meet as
often as they would like and and get as
much work done but but the point I
wanted to make is uh there's been
numerous conversations with my peers and
so for just not just this bill but the
other ones that we sponsor here today
and they all agree that it's it is
important to do some housekeeping and
make sure that the rsas are as clear and
consistent as we can make them
a quick follow-up
uh follow-up go ahead yeah
it's Sullivan County is the only County
that's coming up with Clearing House of
housekeeping
are there any other counties that have
agreed and said the work was began but
it wasn't completed so are any other
counties that are saying yes we need to
reach out to are
reps to
come up with the bills to clarify this
I can't speak for any conversations that
have taken place for in other counties I
do know that this Bill had one other
co-sponsor uh from Rockingham County
um
so I you know without knowing the exact
details and what the threshold is for
how many different co-sponsors from
different counties it takes to really
send a message that there's widespread
agreement
um I can just tell you from my
conversations with my peers
um that the my fellow administrators and
managers haven't disagreed with anything
that we submitted it's just it comes
down to who has time to do the work and
so I guess I'm the sucker that raised my
hand and representative Aaron in
Sullivan County has been gracious enough
to sponsor as many bills as as I could
send her way and so I think that's
probably the biggest reason why I'm here
today and and she's the one that
sponsored all those bills I guess we're
just a gluttons for punishment
representative service
again for taking my question thank you
Mr chair
um
previous questioner mentioned how this
might affect other counties
speaking as a member of the Grafton
County delegation
striking the language about ratified by
a majority vote of the County Convention
it would never fly in Grafton County
so it definitely would have an impact on
other counties
um
so I I guess I'm just looking more for
along the lines of asking you
what was the nature of your conversation
with your colleagues at the County
commission level
was it did it get into the nitty-gritty
of this is the line we want to strike
from this piece of legislation or this
is the broad umbrella under which we'd
like to make these changes would can you
characterize for me which that was
um thanks for the question
Representatives Davis uh
I guess I'd say the answer is a little
bit of both
um the the more detailed discussions
happened within the the context of the
strategy committee so it wasn't
necessarily all 10 Representatives
because the strategy committee
oftentimes to have a corn we just needed
five and so if the debate was or the
discussion was with just five or six
people
um I can tell you when it came down to
this specific
um Bill and again we focused on the word
custody originally
um one of the other uh one of my other
peers mentioned well let's go back and
look at what the powers are that are
enumerated in RSA 24 colon 13 to the
delegation and that's where you know he
made the point that
that's where the term real estate is
used and notably the word property
whether it's personal property real
property or just property writ large is
not mentioned and so again we're we're
trying to put our historical slash
attorney hats on and say well what was
the original intent and it seems as
though if there was a distinction that
was intentional
um that it's real estate is in the
legislative branch and the real property
that's on top of that real estate is the
purview of the executive branch but but
again that's
you know it's impossible for any of us
in this room to go back and really say
with certainty but I think you can you
know make an inference based on the
presence or absence of certain
terminology so I would say if
if the assumption is that the
legislative branch does have purview
over will property then my question
would be why isn't it enumerated in RSA
24 colon 13. so it's
I guess there's a couple different ways
of trying to
evaluate the issue
okay thank you very much I think we've
pretty much beaten this a dead horse on
this point we're going to move on uh
just so you know Mr Ferlin we did find
your pink card for 43 so you don't have
to fill out another one
uh like to call our next uh
witness Sherry and I cannot make out the
last name
Sherry dutzy okay
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members uh I'm representative Sherry
detsee Nashua Ward three uh I also chair
the Hillsborough County delegation
um I'm very new at that so everybody
here knows a lot more about County
government than I do but the reason I'm
here today
um is because I was concerned about the
wording on hb43 that it does take
before we proceed could you state
whether you're in favor I'm sorry I'm
opposed to hb43
um because it takes away the power from
the county delegation the way we operate
in Hillsboro is our County Executive
Board meets on a monthly basis
so during that time it's it's pretty
timely for us to deal with any issues
that are coming up
secondly at our organizational meeting
um we make a number of motions in which
the members of the delegation at that
point give power to the executive
committee so that we can operate on
their behalf when it comes time you know
for buying or selling or doing anything
where it would in the past it might need
getting together the delegation in
Hillsborough County we have 123
delegates we have uh 19 on our executive
board we never have a problem getting a
quorum on our executive board which
again meets monthly
so for us it would be unwieldy to try to
do a County Convention every time we had
an issue so that's why these motions are
made and the executive board operates on
behalf of the delegation
we do have an operating manual that are
attorney for the county gave me and one
of the things that it does note under
our powers and these are issues that I
don't understand the process completely
but I unders I guess that various
counties can operate under rules that
may have been grandfathered in and these
rules are being operated under
Rockingham County and Hillsborough
County but basically under the powers it
says that we we have the power to raise
County taxes to make Appropriations for
the use of the county and to authorize
the purchase of real estate for its use
the sale and convey conveyance of its
real estate the erection enlargement or
repair of its buildings exceeding an
expensive five thousand dollars and the
issuing of bonds for its debt shall be
vested in the County Convention okay so
any change to this law would take away
our powers
um we don't see a problem it's been
working very very well
um so we would be against
um making any changes to this thank you
thank you for your testimony any
questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
I have no more pink cards on uh HB
sporty and what are we on 43 have no
more pink cards anybody else
okay we'll close the hearing on HP 43.
okay we'll open up the hearing on HB 75
now
and hello again representative Aarons
Aaron
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee
for hearing this bill
I'm going to make this very short
um
this bill merely increases the threshold
of county-owned personal property
subject to competitive bidding
when RSA 28 colon
8-a was adopted it was 1959.
based on the inflation calculator the
current value of an item worth three
hundred dollars in 1959
is three thousand and fifty four dollars
it makes sense therefore to update this
statute to reflect the true value of
property
uh county-owned personal property
because of inflation
and I hope that you will vote to pass
this and update the RSA thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative are there any
questions
uh seeing none around the table I have
I have a couple one at least one for you
sure
um
when it talks about and you may not know
the answer to this uh when it talks
about the sale of personal property does
that is that a single item or can it be
a combined
number of items uh do you know I don't
know
thank you
there any other questions
representative Gallagher
um okay okay so uh I was just looking
back at our other bills
um to look at House Bill 148
um
which is also about
uh thresholds for competitive build
bidding and you know it's the same
RSA is 28 8. so um I'm just kind of
wondering if
um you could
help lay out the like do do a compare
and contrast of like what exactly
what why there are two separate bills
here
um to do similar things
thank you representative Gallagher um I
had no idea
about HB 148 being presented so I don't
know I hadn't spoken at all to the
um the sponsor so I didn't even know
that existed
are there any further questions
thank you representative Aaron thank you
Mr furland you're up again
uh thank you Mr chair and members of the
of the committee uh Derek Ferrell and
Sullivan County Manager testifying in
support and uh really have nothing to
add in 1959 I think says it all in the
inflation calculator I think it speaks
for itself thank you
for the questions
seeing none thank you
that is the last pink card we have on
this is for the next one okay that's all
we have on that so we will close the
hearing on hb75
thank you
okay we're gonna go ahead and uh next
bill HP 80 open up the hearing on that
Now for Something Completely Different
representative Aaron
thank you Mr chair
I do appreciate everybody's
um attention and uh questions on on
these uh couple of bills
so this is um hb80 and this bill
clarifies the exemption of County
Administration buildings from Taxation
and provides for taxation of
county-owned lands and buildings leased
by the county to third parties for
farming our agricultural use
so the reason why this bill came about
was I was informed that there have been
instances where the assessors have been
confused on the issue of what's to be
taxed and what's not to be and what's to
be exempt
so there needs there seems to be a need
to clarify this statute and distinguish
County Land that's used for farming and
agricultural use versus
County Land that's used for public
access and use
um and again this was something that was
presented to me by Sullivan County
Manager Derek ferland I'm sure that he
can give you more background on this
particular
issue and that's all I have to say in
terms of introducing this legislation
I think a rep 7 Aaron uh representative
power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question if I'm not mistaken
when I read the
um the build text here
the the first sentence is an incomplete
sentence
like I'm not seeing a verb
because there's a period after the word
buildings
am I missing something
I think I'd have to take a look at let
me see rsh 7223
um
you're right yeah
I think it's because
of the RSA probably says
such and such and such
it shall be taxed
which is in the RSA right but if there's
breaking up
yeah
correct
and they didn't
right
can I follow up uh follow uh yeah I'm
not sure here could I comment I believe
uh representative Powers is correct if
you have a follow-up question yes go
ahead
um representative Hicks that was thank
you Mr chair
um and thank you for the taking my
question that was my question as well
and did you mean or to read shall not be
taxed
I think it should be Shelby text shall
be taxed at the end I guess that must
have been something I overlooked from
OLS I'm sorry
I think that's correct I think those
three words should be in there so that
that'll require
an amendment representative Aaron
okay thank you
representative uh represents Davis thank
you Mr chair
so
you're not sure what the intent of this
amendment is no I am still be taxed or
shall lost okay so the way this reads
lands and buildings and personal
property owned and used by any County
for governmental purposes including
hospitals courthouses registry buildings
and County correctional facilities and
County Administration buildings shall be
taxed so they left out OLS apparently
left out the Shelby tax part and I
didn't touch that when I saw that
uh follow-up go ahead thank you Mr chair
so I think it requires a little bit more
work than that because of the Clause
except the County farms and their lands
buildings and taxable personal property
shall be taxed
and so that is a a clause within the
sentence so there's something definitely
wrong with the with the with the
drafting here yeah well the way they did
it they struck out the entire thing from
except to the word taxed when they
should have struck out what I'm asking
is what is the intent of the bill that
they be taxed or they not be taxed
that those items shall be taxed and the
ones that are mentioned
um
the ones that are the the ones that
shall not be that are accepted from that
are the the in my bill land in buildings
for farming or agricultural use operated
by the county and land in buildings for
farming or agricultural use leased by
the county shall be taxed
I'm gonna suggest is it a question you
can hold for
uh Mr ferland or
why don't we do that
um
if nobody else has any particular
questions for representative Aaron last
uh next
pink card holder Mr furland come up and
maybe
he has a more definitive
answers on some of these things
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh Derek Ferrell and Sullivan
County Manager of testifying in support
of this bill
um so the I apologize for the oversight
I I was also asked to review the the
product when it came out from OLS and I
missed it as well
um the intent was that the first
sentence was shall not be taxed it's to
distinguish the county administrative
buildings and functions and distinguish
them from the remnants of the County
Farms either for the counties that still
have
um land that's leased to third parties
or operate a farm internally
so the way this came about as as
representative Aaron said it was um an
interaction that we had with the
assessors there's contract Assessors for
the town of unity and so we just had a
lot of back and forth about Again The
evolutionary nature of County government
at least in Sullivan County we have uh
buildings on our campus in unity that
used to be part of the County Farm uh
the hay barn and we have another an old
heifer Barn as well as some other sheds
that were Once Upon a Time fully
involved and used solely for the County
Farm function and they are now used for
County storage in fact our hay barn is
used to park the uh the activities bus
for our nursing home as well as a couple
of Emergency Response trailers for the
State Police our Sheriff's Office and
the public health network
so those tax cards still have
contradictory information because the
title will say hay barn County Farm and
the assessors wanted to tax us under the
provision of the of RSA 72 where it says
County Farms will be taxed and we said
well it's not part of the farm anymore
it's part of the uh County Complex and
is used for governmental purposes and
therefore should not be taxed so that
was really the the series of exchanges
that we've had over the last couple of
years with the the assessing Department
uh the contract assessor and so we just
wanted to again add some clarity to
distinguish those uh buildings that are
purely for the purposes of the County
government as opposed to those that
still support a farming operation and we
do have land leases and so those not
only the land but the outbuildings that
support and are included in those leases
we fully agree should be taxed and our
leases actually reflect that so we
collect enough revenue on those leases
to pay the tax bills so we have no
quarrel with the fact that County
farming operations are a separate
taxable activity uh we're just trying to
again clear up
any confusion over what's a purely
governmental purpose versus an
agricultural purpose in the context of
the County Farms
questions
representative majority thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so if I understand your
situation you have buildings which were
were once and are now not
but isn't that something that can be is
that something that can be clarified by
your assessor to reassign what the
building is and therefore is is this
bill specific to you are you looking
more in the in the Universal sense of of
clarifying something or both
thanks for the question
um representative I I think the answer
is a little bit of both I mean we I
could show you uh volumes of email
traffic back and forth trying to
persuade uh the contract assessing
company that our interpretation of the
RSA was was in fact correct and we
disagreed with their interpretation and
I guess the resolution is either you go
to court or you try to get the the law
Rewritten and clarified and this is the
route that we chose I just I'm not sure
what else there is to do when you have
two parties that are reading the same
statutes and they just simply disagree
on what they say so this was the this
was the the route that we chose
foreign
hiding over here in the corner thanks
for spending the day with us it's great
to have you would you agree or would you
think that this is similar to a
situation where a church owns a parking
lot and the church is not taxed because
they're a church a religious community
um
they decide that they can lease their
parking lot to the nightclub next door
different uses different times all the
above and all of a sudden the church
gets a tax bill for the parking lot even
though they still own it
but they've used it for a commercial
purpose not a religious purpose so it's
um liable for that tax
does that make sense to you same idea
thank you for the question
um before I answer I'd probably reinsert
the caveat that I am neither an attorney
nor a historian but what I would say uh
yes I agree philosophically that's I
don't think this case is that much
different than than what you just
described thank you very much
are there any further questions
okay seeing no others I do have oh sorry
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh we had a lot of
conversation about grammar and I just
want to be clear about where we are in
it
um because
yeah no because the last sentence says
the land and buildings for farm and
agricultural use operated by the county
shall be taxed and is your goal to keep
it as shall not be taxed
no okay no the shall not be taxed should
be inserted at the end of the first
sentence
so it would say
um lands and buildings and personal
property owned and used by any County
for governmental purposes including
hospitals courthouses registry buildings
County correctional facilities and
County Administration buildings shall
not be taxed
and then the rest of it the land and
buildings for farming shall be taxed in
accordance with RSA 72 colon 23 Section
1 subsection B
okay thank you
representative you Keller
thank you and thank you for taking the
question
um this section of law is is all part of
of
uh the section that starts reading the
following real estate and personal items
shall be uh shall uh unless otherwise
provided by actually be exempt and so
this is just part of that list of the
things that are exempt
um so I I do
um I think I get what you're trying to
say but my question is in these last two
sentences
um do you believe that they need to be
two separate sentences since the
since it's both land and buildings for
farming or out agricultural
um
use do you believe that there's any
reason why those two sentences can not
be combined into the dude
to who is running them
I guess it says Landing buildings for
farming and agricultural use operated by
and then it says Landing using farming
agricultural use lease by so is there
any reason why you can see that those
shouldn't just be combined into one
sentence
I don't think so
um I think that would be
an appropriate
change uh if it's if your goal is just
to simplify it and have fewer sentences
I don't see any problem with that okay
thank you
representative power
thank you Mr chairman um I apologize for
not
um being up to speed on effective dates
I do recall having researched that a
couple years ago
and um so specifically could you please
explain why that this act shall take
effect of April 1st 2024 which the
rationale for April 1st
uh thank you for the question versus
inner power I I can't answer that I
don't know I was only focused on the
verbiage
um the effective date
I'm not sure
are there any further questions
seeing none we will thank you for your
testimony again and we will close the
hearing on HB 80.
okay it is 2 45
so we will continue on our list HB 83
relative to County Commissioners
Authority on County
buildings representative air
thank you very much and just before I
say something about that on this past
bill that we went through I'm going to
be submitting an amendment to fix that I
would say that would be a very good idea
thank you
I don't need you to do the work right
okay
um
so this is HB 83
and what this one does is it removes
references to expense thresholds for
County Commissioners authority to
purchase real estate and repair enlarge
or erect County buildings
in the first two sections of this bill
RSA 28 colon 5 and RSA 28 colon 7
authorization from the County Convention
is required and this dollar threshold is
already articulated
in RSA 2413
so duplicating the threshold in RSA 28
colon 5 and RSA colon 20 28 colon 7.
merely introduces the probability for
error if either of these or RSA 24 colon
13 is ever updated
so I'm recommending this change so that
the dollar amount can be referenced in
one place
the repeal of RSA 30-b colon 2 is
requested
because this RSA is entirely redundant
with RSA 28 colon 7 and RSA 20 72 colon
23.
so that's the Crux of this particular
piece of legislation
and I'd be happy to comment and also uh
Sullivan County Manager Derek Ferlin can
offer further comments on this
your testimony is complete I assume so
okay thank you uh questions
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
another question I'm looking at HB 83
that you just introduced which
requires that it be authorized by the
County Convention
and then I'm looking back at HP 43 which
was previously introduced which removed
the authority of the County Convention
can you
make that make sense for me why it
should require the County Convention in
one and not the other
well I guess we had discussed about the
difference between
real real estate and real property
um so I guess that's the distinction
oh representative manager Puti thank you
Mr chair thank you representative for
taking my question
um
I want to put it in a succinct way it's
in my mind this is creating more
confusion in terms of rsa's the
evolution and what it is instead of
clarifying can you help me
understand
how this is clarifying versus creating
more confusion
because if you look at RSA 2413
which I've misplaced
um the dollar threshold for doing these
kinds of transactions is already stated
so it's almost a duplication for it to
be
uh
in RSA 28 5 and 28 7. that's
why
um representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so I'm also
thoroughly confused
by the drafting of this particular bill
so on section three where it says repeal
could you just clarify the way that that
wording is
it states relative to County Corrections
real estate in buildings is comma is
repealed
that's is that some type of an
explanation or title
I'm just confused
so I understand that you want to repeal
RSA 30-b colon to
I'm just confused by that language yeah
um let me just look and see
okay RSA 30
um Dash B colon two
um
so if you look at RSA 28 colon 7
it says when so authorized by the County
Convention they may purchase real estate
as may be required for County
correctional facilities including County
Farms or other uses they may repair a
large or erect County buildings at a
cost exceeding five thousand dollars
and with like Authority they may sell
any of the County's real estate so
a
if RSA 30-b colon 2 is redundant to that
foreign
if RSA 30-b colon 2 is repealed my
question is Will County correctional
facilities then shall they be exempt
from taxation
what that's a good question I would like
to defer that to our uh our Sullivan
County Manager
no they're repealing this
so they were repealing this
you know by repealing it
can I can I just make a statement
um we will continue with questions first
representative anybody else
um
representative majority
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I'll bring
that a little bit closer
um
with regard to 28.5 and the five
thousand dollars yep I I understand I
understand your explanation has there
been a stated problem or confusion
between
24 13 and 28 5 where this will fix those
historical problems or is this more of a
housekeeping I think it's more of a
housekeeping okay thank you
your mic's on I didn't know if you
wanted to okay
okay further questions thank you
thank you representative Aaron
Mr Berlin welcome back uh thank you Mr
chair members of the committee uh Derek
Ferrell in Sullivan County uh manager
and testifying in support of this bill
um
just add a bit of context the this bill
emanated from uh my research on the next
bill which was starting out looking at
the threshold and updating that but when
I was doing the cross-referencing it
just occurred to me that we have a
dollar threshold referenced in three
separate
um rsas and it just introduces the
opportunity for error if you ever do
change the threshold you might not
intuitively understand that it's it
appears in others so the the references
in the county commissioner chapter of
chapter 28 so RSA is I think it's 28 is
it 28 5 and 28 7.
yes 25 and 28 7. really the specifying
the dollar value is is to me is is uh is
redundant
um the when the budget is approved any
repair projects or capital projects are
generally either depending on how the
county does it identified by line item
or enumerated in the context of a
maintenance and repair budget so
um I just felt that there wasn't any
additional value added by specifying the
dollar value because if you change RSA
24 colon 13
um that's where the you know the
delegation's oversight and approval of
those projects now one of the
justifications for increasing that
threshold which I guess I'll get to in
the next hearing so I I guess I'll table
that remark
um
but I guess it does come up because it's
in response to the previous question
um there are instances when we are
making repairs that do exceed five
thousand dollars uh we had a heat
exchanger in the nursing home about a
year and a half ago that failed and I
believe it was like a thirteen thousand
dollar repair given the emergency nature
of of that particular issue we certainly
didn't have time to go back and get the
the county delegation to convene a
meeting and and approve it so
um but they did approve and appropriate
a maintenance and repair budget and
that's where we drew the funding from so
I guess in that particular instance the
threshold did matter and it was in
response to a particular situation but
really this did stem from
um the desire to update House Bill 87
which is in line with previous bills
which is just a matter of keeping up
with keeping up with the times
oh and I guess I also say Mr chair
um in response to any confusion about
the previous Bill House Bill 43 uh this
is specifically
in relation to building or enlarging or
repairing as opposed to the disposal and
so I do think there is a clear
distinction as to what this bill is
trying to fix and I don't think it
without getting into the whole real
estate versus Real Property discussion
but I do think 288c is clearly on the
disposition end of it and this is on the
enlarging or erecting which I do think
if you're going to build a building that
absolutely the delegation should know
about it which is why
um you know I again have no issue with
the oversight on that end of it but once
it's built I guess the broader legal
question is who then has the authority
to uh to dispose of it knowing that
you're not going to sell a building
without also addressing the land under
it but
um and then 25
000 as opposed to 5 000 is this you know
we we put up a a shed in our community
garden this past year and that cost
eight thousand and um
at the risk of in um incriminating
myself I will tell you we absolutely
just did that without the delegations
explicit approval other than the funds
that were appropriated in the budget so
you know you could say that we had the
approval because they did approve the
budget but it wasn't like we're going to
go to them with a line item approval for
an eight thousand dollar shed but
I guess I'll wait for the
sergeant-at-arms to handle
okay oh and Mr chair I sorry there to
clear up any other confusion thank you
Kate for
um the question on RSA 30 Dash B colon
2. um I'll just read it verbatim so it's
under the Department of Corrections
statute and it says 30-b colon 2 real
estate semicolon buildings in accordance
with RSA 287 when authorized by the
County Convention the County
Commissioners May purchase such real
estate as may be required for a County
correctional facility and may repair
enlarge or erect County buildings
housing County correctional facilities
and may sell any of the County's real
estate
as provided in RSA 72 colon 3 section 2
County correctional facilities shall be
exempt from taxation except that County
farms and their lands buildings and
taxable personal property shall be taxed
so everything in that chapter is covered
almost word for word in either rsas 28 7
or 7223 I mean it is completely
redundant serves no purpose and has no
value hence the the recommendation to
simply delete it in the interest of of
housekeeping in this case
thank you yeah thank you
questions
I see nothing
that was the last pink card
anybody else want to submit a pink card
before we close the hearing
okay seeing none we closed the hearing
on HB 83.
okay
okay it is three o'clock we'll open up
the hearing on our last bill of the day
HB 87 representative Aaron
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
committee for all your patience and
questions on all of these bills
um
this is hb30 HB 87
and this bill raises the monetary cap on
the value of enlargements or repairs to
County buildings vested in the County
Convention
currently RSA 24 colon 13 uses five
thousand dollars as a benchmark for
Capitol building project thresholds in
today's times and especially with
inflation twenty five thousand dollars
is a widely used threshold to
distinguish capital projects and repairs
from non-capital projects and repairs
capital projects are normally singled
out for approval in a county budgeting
process so the delegation oversight and
approval of these projects would be
accomplished during each budget cycle
anyway
I think that our rsas need to reflect
the reality of the cost of capital
building projects
five thousand dollars is not realistic
anymore doing so would not uh
so doing so would not only make our
current rsas realistic but also save
time requiring delegation oversight and
approval for projects that really should
not require that time
and that's what this bill is all about
so thank you
thank you representative
are there any questions
representative status
thank you Mr chair and thank you once
again representative Aaron
um my question about this particular
bill goes to the delegation's authority
to
tax tax
citizens to Levy County taxes and in
part that Authority is based on the
expenses that the county must incur on
behalf of its citizens
so I I'm wondering
I'm wondering why you think that 25 000
is an appropriate amount given how tight
most County budgets are and how
reluctant most County delegates are to
raise County taxes
thank you for your question
well the five thousand dollars in this
particular statute
um
is a benchmark on Capitol building
projects and we've seen the Capitol
building projects
are are um typically much more expensive
and even yes while we have an eye on
wanting to
um you know not raise taxes and be
mindful of how much our Capitol Building
expenses are
nonetheless
um you know with with these uh expenses
it would seem to me that you would need
County Convention approval much more
often
than
for a five thousand dollar ticketed item
a capital project than you would for
something more expensive
and I think we would you know with this
it's just a more realistic number for
many of the Capitol building projects
that we're seeing in in our
in our projects for you know in in the
county in the county
you know needs
representative lasalles
yes thank you for uh
taking my question
in several of these bills we've talked
about thresholds
and in periods of
inflation
like we've had in the last couple of
years
these thresholds become very important
all through government spending at least
in one case we applied a measure of
inflation
uh I think it was CPI
so that the thresholds would not
become obsolete
immediately and become more so as time
went on depending on what the inflation
is I'm just wondering in all of these
cases where we have thresholds applied
would it behoove us to apply some
measure of inflation so that next year
if if the inflation rate becomes
30 percent or if there is a deflation
that that would automatically kick into
gear
representative La sells I think that's a
an excellent observation that perhaps
that many of these statutes that we have
that have dollar amounts or thresholds
like this should indeed be more likely
would be more more
um
better written
to have some sort of
you know Mark to to the rate of
inflation instead of a dollar number but
we see you know dollar numbers in our
statute so I was just looking to make
that adjustment
but it wouldn't be unreasonable to tie
it to an inflation gauge of some sort
excuse me representative menchaputi
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um
sitting
you know counties that have
Hillsborough County that has a large
delegation
and having set on the executive
committee these thresholds have worked
well in terms of having the checks and
balances
and uh so by changing you've seen like
by changing in one representative will
suspend um could you please again try to
keep
to questions on the
on the bill itself rather than getting
into
I don't want to say personal history or
whatever but let's try to keep this as
quick as we can representative manager
Puti question clarifying uh testimony
thank you
thank you Mr I'll try to because each
bill is kind of tying into the other so
every time I ask a question on one bill
the next bill changes that or affects
that so there is a cascading effect on
all the bills that so far so I mean
changing one RSA in one place it has a
cascading effect have you looked at that
in a totality
how it's going to impact different
locations different
rsas that are tied into
I guess I'm not clear on what your
question is insofar as does this bill
um how how it affects multiple counties
or multiple other statutes I mean what
what I'm trying to do here is to just
put in a measure of reality as to how
much our Capital
Improvement projects the building
projects actually cost these days I
don't know that you can ever find a
capital building project that's uh
uh five thousand dollars anymore
and so if you would see if there was a
capitol building
project that was that amount of money
um
that would be more more times that you
would have to call the County Convention
together for any kind of uh vote on it
I got one clarifying question along the
lines of Representative mandaputi's
question is we've seen a lot of
different bills today with a lot of
dollar figures changing authorized by
this authorized by that
I think the question is
in this case does this bill changing
that dollar value effect
other parts of the rsas that might that
was one of my questions does it impact
or conflict with other parts of the rsas
I don't believe so okay
uh representative Tatro
thanks for taking my question now that
you can hear me
um
I'm confused and I hope you can clarify
clarify it for me
um
I realized this the only change in in
this bill is is a dollar amount by the
looks of things that yes correct okay
thank you
um but how
does does this
RSA
authorize
the county
to
issue bonds
without going through the proper
procedure or am I confused
no you'd still have to issue
well it says the power to raise County
taxes to make Appropriations for the use
of the county and to authorize the
purchase of real estate for its use the
sale and conveyance of its real estate
the erection enlargement or repair of
its buildings exceeding an expensive
five thousand dollars we want to raise
that to twenty five thousand and the
issuing of bonds for its debt shall be
vested in the County Convention so you'd
still have
um you know the the County Convention
um you know needing to approve any kind
of issuing of bonds and debts
uh
but it would be at a higher dollar
amount because the the capital
Improvement projects normally are not
five thousand dollars anymore right
thank you
any further questions
representative uh yokella thank you
thank you for taking the question
um you keep on talking about Capital
Improvement projects but in fact isn't
it the case that you're also
um
raising the requirement for approval for
repairs to buildings
from five thousand dollars so if you
need you know five thousand dollar fix
of of a plumbing issue versus a twenty
five thousand dollar fix of appointment
May issue only when it reached the level
of a twenty five thousand dollar
plumbing issue fix would you need to go
to the convention
okay so but the thing is that Capital
repairs and projects from non-capital
projects and repair well
we have to distinguish the value amounts
of this of capital projects and repairs
from non-capital projects and repairs
and what we're seeing is these capital
projects and repairs are no longer
around the amount of five thousand
dollars
and non-capital projects and repairs are
already covered in in our budgets
so the dollar amounts for those usually
are you know we anticipate how much
we're going to need for those kinds of
projects
come on
yes uh representative Gilman thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
for taking my question
um I think part of what's
a problem here and you can tell me if
this is consistent this is what we've
been trying to get at
um
most of these are even maybe all of
these bills that reference a dollar cap
or a dollar figure
some of them are about revenue and some
of them are about sale or or income for
the county
does this does this last bill which
refers to both of those the sale or
um you know revenue or an expenditure
just get us all messed up again
well this is uh regarding buildings
exceeding uh the enlargement or repair
of its buildings exceeding it's the
capital
building expense
five thousand dollars so and but we're
saying that you you won't really see
that amount anymore that the the Capitol
Building expenses are much more
expensive than five thousand dollars
hello Mr sure go ahead
I I understand that
um and I agree that you know 5000 is no
longer uh it doesn't get you much but it
does say in the second line real estate
for its use the sale in conveyance as
well as the erection and enlargement and
repair so and previously we got rid of
the County Convention having to deal
with any of
I don't know the
small smaller smaller items smaller
things that you don't want to you know
draw the whole County Convention to so
my question is are we are we once again
getting confused but because we're we're
using both uh the expenditure funds and
the intake of funds sale versus
erection of an enlargement I I think
thank you for your question I I think
that this is just
um trying to distinguish between
the reality of what
[Music]
um
are are real capital building project
thresholds are
um and and what the non-capital projects
and repairs actually cost
so
thank you I think it would be fair to
say that this particular paragraph is on
County Convention Powers it's a laundry
list of individual items that the County
Convention has
rule over if you will
am I miss I think that's fair to say yes
right okay thank you
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so due to the fact
that this particular bill
involves the enlargement or repair
or the erection of buildings as does the
previous Bill 83
and furthermore since
both statutes reference a a dollar
threshold of five thousand and in this
one the you're changing striking the
5000 and making it twenty five thousand
whereas in the previous bill it's been
deleted do you
is there a sense that this might be
incongruent with each other and there
may be a problem
I don't think so but I would defer that
question to our County Manager
okay thank you representative Aaron
last but not least
Mr perlin
before you start Miss Ferlin I think
there's maybe a general sense maybe I'm
misreading it but I think
a bunch of us
kind of
believe that a lot of these changes may
be interfering with impacting
conflicting with others
um and I'm not sure how that's going to
be
excuse me thanks Mr chair but yes excuse
me
um
I must ask a point of order it's very
clear that we don't impugn
um others thoughts or ideas when we're
on the house floor and I think that the
same thing holds here so I'd prefer that
you not State how I might be feeling in
regards to any of this thank you sure
I'll take that under advisement
representative so go ahead
uh thank you Mr chair and once again
members of the committee uh Derek
Ferrell and Sullivan County Manager
testifying in support of house bill 87.
um
very simply the the dollar threshold
raise was really pegged to our
um counties approach to Capital versus
non-capital projects uh I referenced my
my prior career as an Air Force civil
engineer
um 25 000 was was widely accepted and I
would go so far as to say an industry
standard for what's deemed to be a
capital project and so we that's how we
internally treat uh during our budget
process there are things that we know
are going to repair that are just
run-of-the-mill repairs to our
facilities and those May cost you know
anywhere from very little very few
dollars to sometimes very thousands of
dollars but we make a distinction with
anything that's going to be projected to
cost over 25 000 it gets its own
treatment in our budget and in our
budget presentations
um so this was just an attempt to try to
standardize that language I would say
that regardless of whether it's a repair
that's done under our other budget
category for just general maintenance
and repair of different facilities the
delegation has oversight of all of that
just by virtue of of appropriating and
passing a budget we just provide special
attention to those repairs that we call
Capital and we've Associated that with a
25 000 threshold
um in reference to the previous
questions about cascading and impacts of
other rsas the answer is yes that's
specifically why we struck the reference
to five thousand dollars and 28.5 and
28.7 just to clarify it because they are
all interchanged but it should only be
referenced once in my opinion just for
Simplicity and to avoid the possibility
of introducing unforced errors so once
the County Convention has approved a
budget which includes sub-capital as
well as capital requirements then all
the other rsas simply fall in line once
you have that Authority that's been
provided by the by the convention
I think there was another question
I apologize that's escaping me
um
well I guess I'll end it there and wait
for any other follow-up questions thanks
Mr chair okay thank you for your
testimony any questions
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
for taking a question so to the point
that you just raised about
um the cascading effect or or trying to
eliminate or prevent that cascading
effect
would it make any sense to then state in
these proposed bills a clause as
referenced in RSA whatever it is because
and I asked that question because
otherwise I as a freshman or a layperson
has no idea that there is any other
reference anywhere else and I say that
with all due respect that that may
create an entirely
onerous problem of administration for
you but I
otherwise I don't know how to get around
this so I apologize for the lengthy
question Mr chair
thank you representative I I
wholeheartedly agree if I understand you
correctly what I would Envision then is
in rsas 28 5 and 7 for example we could
add a little Clause that says as per RSA
2413 and then everything points back to
the source document and I I think that
would be a a value-added amendment to
those other rsas just to make sure that
everything's in sync oh I do remember Mr
chair what I was going to say before
about the um uh the question from
representative LaSalle is about whether
or not we should do an index reference
inflation versus coming back every so
often to have these discussions uh which
I've enjoyed thoroughly uh you guys
probably might I might disagree but I I
think it's it's whichever way we want to
go about it I think if you do the
inflationary index you never have to
come back and see me again
um but then you'd have authorization
limits that one year it's a nice round
number like three thousand or five
thousand and then the next year it's
five thousand and eleven and probably
with some pennies and I think that would
be a little bit awkward but certainly
not inaccurate and it would avoid the
administrative headache of having to
come back and do this so it's I guess
there are probably equal pros and cons
to whichever approach but at least
having um
the ability to come have a discussion
you can you know I guess decide what
makes more sense if you're just strictly
following inflation then decide whatever
that index should be and and call it a
day
um
darn it I did it again I had two points
and now the other one escaped me so I
apologize
are there any further questions
oh
I got it back uh regarding the the
comment about the the
um
the conflicting all these rsas I can I
can appreciate I live this every almost
every day probably weekly I'm digging
into the RSA so I can appreciate that
I've got a lot more familiarity for
better or worse than you all do and I
agree it can be probably a bit daunting
I do think if you break it down into the
the terminology and thinking about what
do we think the the framers of our rsas
meant by the enumerated powers in terms
of what's real estate real property I
think there's some tweaks that could
absolutely benefit and clear things up
um but I also think that when we looked
at the various rsas we talk about the
difference of enlarging or erecting
buildings versus disposing and so I
think those are all
distinct actions that these bills if you
go back and look at them again I think
there are there's less overlap in
confusion than maybe what appears today
because you've just gotten the fire hose
treatment of getting bombarded with all
eight chapters of the county rsas that
probably before today you might not have
even known existed so
um I do think there's it's more distinct
in separate Lanes of action that we're
requesting and I do think if you trace
it all back it does preserve the
authority and legal responsibility of
each branch of government I do think it
there's a nice perfect complementary
relationship between what the delegation
is required to do and then what the
Commissioners are required to do as per
the rsas I just think with a few little
tweaks we could clear up any
misunderstandings or confusion and and
we'll all be much better off for it
thanks Mr chair
for the questions uh representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for thank you for taking another
question that last statement that you
made is exactly what I was trying to get
to so my question is why does this one
use the word sale
and
erection and enlargement and give it a
dollar value that um
shall be vested in the County Convention
and the other ones take the sale out you
know or take it away from the County
Convention
thank you representative Gilman for the
question that actually is another thing
that I forgot to mention which is I
would strongly Advocate as a non uh
granitarian uh English major but I did
have Mr Couture for eighth grade eighth
grade English and grammar and he was
phenomenal
um I think that there should be
semicolons delineating the items in that
list to distinguish those commas from
the comma that appears between the words
erection and enlargement
uh because I think the 25 000 is meant
to only apply to the section that says
the erection enlargement or repair of
its buildings exceeding an expense of 25
000 and using semicolons for the other
items would clearly indicate that the 25
000 does not apply to the purchase of
real estate uh the sale and conveyance
of its real estate so I think that's
where commas versus semicolons matter
and I think this is one indication or an
example of where
um it is confusing
were overrun by commas
for the questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
oops having no more pink cards will
close the hearing on HB 87.
so that was our last one for today
um just want to go over next week's
schedule
uh the bill should be posted here
shortly on next Wednesday we will meet
as a committee for uh some more hearings
at 10 o'clock on Wednesday again
the following day Thursday I think
um we mentioned that it's we have just
so many bills we're gonna have to do
more work than a single day at least the
plan is to get ahead rather than fall
behind so on Thursday morning we will
attempt to exec execut exec a lot of the
bills that we did today on Thursday
morning
and then in the F that'll be uh starting
at 10 30 that'll give
um
should you each caucus decide uh to hold
the caucus prior to that uh enough time
to do that so on Thursday morning we'll
begin at 10 30. and then at 1 30 we will
um
do four more
uh bills in a hearing so
Thursday I mean Wednesday it'll be 10
all hearing all Pub uh all bills and
then on Thursday it'll be 10 30 morning
executing bills afternoon four more
bills
representative
so there were several bills um that we
heard today that I believe you would
like to exec next week where we
suggested or asked for amendments and
the sponsors agreed to those amendments
and I would like to see those amendments
prior to executing any of the bills
absolutely any amendments I know we had
some this morning I think
representative Aaron and
the County administrator will have some
amendments for us but that's an
excellent point we should have those uh
at least by Wednesday morning Tuesday
night if you can get them
and it would be helpful
um it was mentioned several times that
if there's one on especially your bills
representative Aaron where we have so
many of them and they all have different
dollar figures if and where they impact
the other if we can somehow reference
that
so we're not so some of us aren't uh
confused by that
did somebody else have a
oh there we go Representatives
I I would think if I think that's an
excellent idea not only because uh it
might
ensure the passage of some of their
bills rather than yes not so that might
be to their advantage to do so yes
yes uh representative
I think it is an excellent idea but the
fact remains that we have heard each
bill individually
and are therefore
under some obligation I mean the bills
are ours now they've come to our
committee in their hours we can do what
we wish but I think that we are under
some obligation to dispose of each bill
individually
um
whether or not we get an overview of all
of them I just I just want to make sure
that we yeah totally understand
to every Bill yes absolutely
any other questions
uh representative
thank you and this is one County out of
10. so we have heard from one County
what they're trying to fix and how it
impacts
uh nine other counties
you know that's for us to make the
determination from where we are coming
from and how it would impact
correct
we don't just some of us do not disagree
with that representative yokella
um thank you uh
in in uh prior sessions
um is my understanding that we can only
um
propose in executive session amendments
that we a member of the
um the committee are uh sponsor of
um
can you have you made a ruling on that
for this term has that role changed I
don't believe the rules changed but
we've had uh individuals the sponsors do
the Amendments before okay I don't see
any different uh change in that okay
okay
I think we're done for the day we'll see
everybody next Wednesday
it is